Welcome back to our second drink of The Meeting. I have a little behind-the-scenes tidbit that I discovered when I was looking back to our first table draft of this episode. This episode was originally titled Jim Goes for it. Well, that kind of feels very on the nose. It does. I guess the meeting is where we settled. Yeah. So we had a fan mail flurry for this one. Jenna, we both said we didn't know who Alan was.
欢迎回到我们《会议》这一集的第二杯饮品时间。在回顾这一集的初稿时，我发现了一个幕后小花絮。这一集最初的标题是《吉姆放手一搏》。嗯，感觉有点太直白了。确实。我想最后还是定为《会议》了。没错。所以这一集我们收到了很多粉丝来信。珍娜，我们俩都说不知道艾伦是谁。
You know, the guy David Wallace says he has to run things by. We were both like, who the heck is Alan? And, you know, he is clearly in charge, but we said we had never heard of him, lady. Yeah, who's Alan? Well, Sarah F. Marlon R and many others wanted us to know that Alan is the CEO of Dundermifflin. And he is mentioned in the pilot episode of the office. It's during Jan's meeting with Michael. And Jan says, Alan and the board have decided that we can't justify a Scranton branch and a Stanford branch. Well, who is David Wallace? David Wallace isn't the CEO? He's not. There's a lot of debate about it. There was a very funny back and forth I saw online where people are like, what exactly is David Wallace?
你知道的，就是大卫·华莱士说他必须把事情先过一遍的那个人。我们俩当时都想，艾伦到底是谁啊？而且，很明显他才是负责人，但我们说从来没听说过他，天哪。是啊，艾伦是谁？好吧，莎拉·F、马龙·R还有许多其他人想让我们知道，艾伦是邓德·米夫林的首席执行官。他在《办公室》的第一集中就被提到了。那是在简和迈克尔开会的时候。简说：“艾伦和董事会已经决定，我们无法证明同时保留斯克兰顿分部和斯坦福分部的合理性。”那么，大卫·华莱士是谁？大卫·华莱士不是首席执行官吗？他不是。关于这一点网上有很多争论。我看到网上有一段非常有趣的来回讨论，人们都在问，大卫·华莱士到底是什么职位？
Like, the role of CEO would never come in and have these like talks with Michael. No, you're right. You know, just the way he pops in and out of the branch is not very CEO-like. I'm going to look it up. I want to know what his official title is. Yeah. What is David Wallace's official title at Dunder Mifflin? Everyone hearing me. Oh. The CFO? And CEO. I know, but he's the CFO from seasons two through six. And then he becomes the CEO?
比如，首席执行官绝不会亲自过来和迈克尔进行这些谈话。不，你说得对。你知道，他进出分部的方式一点也不像个首席执行官。我要查一下。我想知道他的正式头衔是什么。是啊。大卫·华莱士在邓德·米夫林公司的正式头衔是什么？大家听着。哦。首席财务官？还有首席执行官。我知道，但他从第二季到第六季是首席财务官。然后他变成了首席执行官？
But there is a lot of online. There's a lot of online chatter. People are like, listen, David was acting like the owner, the CEO, the CFO, the regional manager, approving random expenses. I know. He was like, I mean, what is going on? This is very funny. Well, apparently, Alan is the biggest deal. Yes.
但网上有很多讨论。人们说，听着，大卫的表现就像个老板、首席执行官、首席财务官、区域经理，还批准各种乱七八糟的开支。我知道。他就像是，我的天，这到底是怎么回事？这太搞笑了。好吧，显然，艾伦才是最大的大人物。是的。
At Dundermifflin, and he and the board make the decisions. Yes. Okay. Okay. So we also got this question from Delaney B. in Lubbock, Texas. Delaney says, when Dwight finds out that Jim got their promotion and Dwight has, has that talking head where he just screams and screams. Was that scripted or did Rain Wilson just make that up?
在邓德·米夫林，他和董事会才做决定。是的。好的。好的。我们还收到了德莱尼·B从德克萨斯州拉伯克发来的这个问题。德莱尼问，当德怀特发现吉姆得到了晋升，而德怀特有一个对着镜头说话的片段，他一直在尖叫。那是剧本写的，还是雷恩·威尔逊自己编的？
Well, this is a great question, Delaney. I went to the script and here's how it read in the shooting draft. Scene 46, Dwight Talking Head, a long, still silence. Then Dwight erupts in an enrage gel. Dwight semicolon, ah! Exclamation point. But Delaney, there were candy bag alts that were, quote, must shoot. So that means these actually got shot.
嗯，这是一个很好的问题，德莱尼。我查了剧本，拍摄草稿上是这样写的。第46场，德怀特对着镜头说话，长时间的静止沉默。然后德怀特爆发出一阵愤怒的尖叫。德怀特分号，啊！感叹号。但是德莱尼，当时有一些“必须拍摄”的备选方案。这意味着这些确实被拍下来了。
Because sometimes we get pages and pages that we didn't even get to. Totally. It was like if time permits. Yeah. But there was must shoot and if time permits. Yeah. Here was must shoot. Dwight could have said, I was chasing mice in the corn crib while a fox was eating my mother's head.
因为有时候我们会有很多页剧本根本没时间拍。完全是这样。就像如果时间允许的话。是的。但有“必须拍摄”和“如果时间允许”。是的。这是“必须拍摄”的内容。德怀特本可以说：“当狐狸在吃我母亲的头时，我正在玉米仓里追老鼠。”
Okay. Or this better be a motherfucking prank. Or the one day I'm distracted is the one day Jim Halpert gets ambitious. That's funny to me. Yeah. Well, Angela, we also had some fun banter in this breakdown. You really got into the whole gray-pupon mustard mention in this episode. And Jessica E. wrote in with this hilarious story.
好的。或者“这最好是个该死的恶作剧”。或者“我唯一分心的一天，就是吉姆·哈珀特变得有野心的一天”。这对我来说很有趣。是啊。好吧，安吉拉，我们在这次解析中也有一些有趣的调侃。你真的深入探讨了这一集中提到的灰庞芥末酱。杰西卡·E写了一封信，讲了一个非常搞笑的故事。
This is amazing. She said that one day her husband pulled up next to a Rolls-Royce, rolled down his window, and asked for some gray poupon as a joke. Because, you know, that's what the commercial was. Right. These two fancy cars pull up next to each other and they ask for gray poupon. Well, Jessica goes on to say, as it turned out, in the backseat of the Rolls-Royce was television actor Eric Estrada. And he had little bottles of gray poupon. That is just so, so amazing that he was ready.
这太神奇了。她说有一天她丈夫把车停在一辆劳斯莱斯旁边，摇下车窗，开玩笑地问有没有灰庞芥末酱。因为，你知道，广告里就是这么演的。对吧。这两辆豪车停在一起，然后他们问有没有灰庞芥末酱。好吧，杰西卡接着说，结果证明，劳斯莱斯的后座坐着电视演员埃里克·埃斯特拉达。而且他随身带着小瓶的灰庞芥末酱。这真是太神奇了，他竟然准备好了。
He was ready for the day that someone said, pardon me, can I have your gray poupon? I mean, that is so funny to me. Does Rolls Royce have a partnership with Gray Poupon where like if you buy a Rolls Roy, you get a few bottles of gray Poupon? I don't know. This is my question. I want them to bring those commercials back, but I want Erica Estrada in them. Yes. Well, we also talked about the storyline of Pam trying to get people to RSVP for her wedding so she can get a headcount.
他为有人说“打扰一下，能给我点灰庞芥末酱吗？”的那一天做好了准备。我的意思是，这对我来说太搞笑了。劳斯莱斯和灰庞芥末酱有合作吗？比如如果你买了劳斯莱斯，就会送几瓶灰庞芥末酱？我不知道。这是我的问题。我希望他们能把那些广告带回来，但我希望埃里克·埃斯特拉达出现在里面。是的。好吧，我们还谈到了帕姆试图让人们回复她的婚礼邀请，以便她能统计人数的情节。
And lady, this sent us on a tangent about bugging the bride on the day of the wedding. and we got this amazing share from Melissa M. who said, For my wedding, I included a sheet in our hotel guest welcome bags that said, call anyone but the bride and gave phone numbers of who to talk to instead for the wedding weekend. Isn't that so great? That is good. That is good. Well, everyone, please enjoy our second drink of the meeting. I'm Jenna Fisher.
天哪，这让我们跑题谈到了在婚礼当天打扰新娘的事。我们收到了梅丽莎·M分享的一个很棒的故事，她说：“在我的婚礼上，我在酒店客人的欢迎礼包里放了一张纸，上面写着：‘除了新娘，给任何人打电话都可以’，并提供了婚礼周末可以联系的人的电话号码。”这不是很棒吗？那很好。那真的很好。好吧，各位，请享受我们的第二杯会议饮品。我是珍娜·费舍尔。
And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello. I just want to say, I am so happy to be sitting across this recording booth table.
我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你进行终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。你好。我只想说，我很高兴能坐在录音棚桌子的对面。
It's a table? Yeah. From my best friend this morning. Thanks, lady. Yeah. I am super peppy. morning. That's awesome. I'm really peppy and I got no sleep, which means I'm more loopy than peppy, so buckle in. What is in store for us today? I don't know. Would you like an update on my
这是一张桌子？是啊。今天早上和我最好的朋友。谢谢你，女士。是啊。我超级兴奋。早上好。那太棒了。我真的很兴奋，而且我没睡够，这意味着我比兴奋更迷糊，所以系好安全带吧。今天有什么在等着我们？我不知道。在开始今天的工作之前，你想听听我关于
contrast showers before we begin today? Uh, yeah. I've taken them to a new level. I don't shower anymore. I'm sorry, what? Well, I mean, I shower. Jennifer, Jenna, Jenna. Obviously, my way of doing the contrast hydrotherapy shower is now I sit in the hot tub and it's super hot and then I do a cold dip in our freezing cold swimming pool. Why, Chema? It is so cold. I am on fire about it. You know what?
冷热交替淋浴的最新进展吗？呃，是的。我已经把它们提升到了一个新的水平。我不再淋浴了。抱歉，什么？好吧，我的意思是，我淋浴。詹妮弗，珍娜，珍娜。显然，我现在进行冷热交替水疗淋浴的方式是，我坐在热水浴缸里，水超级热，然后我在我们冰冷的游泳池里泡一下冷水。为什么，切玛？水太冷了。我对此充满热情。你知道吗？
This is like, this is unlocking something in me. I am like I'm starting to read books about it. Wait, does this mean Office Ladies is going to go somewhere like really icy? and do a polar bear plunge? Are we going to Finland? Are we going to have a shot of like some kind of alcohol and then jump in an icy lake? I don't know if I'm at icy lake yet. I mean, I'm at pretty cold.
这就像，这在我身上开启了某种东西。我好像开始读关于它的书了。等等，这意味着《办公室女士》要去某个非常冰冷的地方吗？还要进行北极熊冬泳？我们要去芬兰吗？我们要喝一杯某种酒精，然后跳进冰冷的湖里吗？我不知道我是否已经准备好去冰冷的湖了。我的意思是，我已经到了相当冷的程度了。
Would you do it, though? No. Here's the thing. Lee is really into it. Lee wants to talk to Josh about it because Josh, you know, is a super healthy guy. Yeah. I think he's going to get Josh to start doing it. Lee and I think maybe 2022 we might get you to do it, Ange.
你会做吗？不会。事情是这样的。李真的很喜欢这个。李想和乔什谈谈，因为乔什，你知道，是一个超级健康的人。是的。我想他会说服乔什开始这样做。李和我认为也许2022年我们可能会让你也这样做，安吉。
No way. I hate being cold. I want it to be something. that you do. No. I don't know why. I don't want to do it. All right, fine. I love it. I would do it on a vacation. I am vacation adventurous. I am not day-to-day adventurous. All right. Take me, you know, somewhere Nordic. Maybe I'll jump in. All right. And holler after I've had a shot of something. Okay. It's probably not the health routine you want. Well, today we are going to talk about the meeting. Which is Season 6, Episode 2.
绝不可能。我讨厌寒冷。我希望这是你做的事情。不。我不知道为什么。我不想做。好吧，随你便。我喜欢它。我会在度假时做。我是度假冒险家。我不是日常冒险家。好吧。带我去，你知道，某个北欧的地方。也许我会跳进去。好吧。喝了一杯什么东西之后再大喊大叫。好吧。这可能不是你想要的健康习惯。好吧，今天我们要谈谈《会议》。这是第六季第二集。
It is written by one of our favorite people, Aaron Scher. Love him. And directed by one of our other favorite people, Randall Einhorn. Yeah. Here's a summary. Jim meets with David Wallace about a possible promotion. Dwight and Toby joined forces to investigate whether Darrell submitted a fraudulent medical claim. And Pam works to lock down her RSVPs for her and Jim's wedding.
它是由我们最喜欢的人之一，亚伦·舒尔编写的。爱他。并由我们另一位最喜欢的人，兰德尔·艾因霍恩执导。是的。这是一个摘要。吉姆与大卫·华莱士会面讨论可能的晋升。德怀特和托比联手调查达里尔是否提交了欺诈性的医疗索赔。帕姆努力敲定她和吉姆婚礼的回复名单。
I found that storyline so relatable. Well, you just RSVP, people. Just RSVP. When Meredith says, I'll just text you the day of the wedding. I mean, did you get texts on the day of your wedding? Because I did. Yeah. I was like, you may not be my friend anymore, person who texted me on my wedding morning to ask me about, like, parking instructions.
我觉得那个情节太有共鸣了。好吧，你们就回复吧，伙计们。回复就行了。当梅雷迪思说：“我会在婚礼当天发短信给你。”我的意思是，你在婚礼当天收到短信了吗？因为我收到了。是的。我当时想，你可能不再是我的朋友了，那个在我婚礼当天早上发短信问我关于停车指南的人。
I got to text the morning of my wedding about, would this outfit be appropriate? What's the attire again? Is it real fancy or could I wear something casual? See, now listen, Angie, if you text me the morning of my wedding to ask me a question, that's fine. But you know what? I wouldn't. That's the difference. BFFs get a pass. BFFs do get a pass, but they also know better. Yeah. Text another wedding guest. You know someone who's going. Text your most reliable friend who saved the invitation. Text the friend you know in the wedding party. Yeah. That's their job. Leave
我在婚礼当天早上收到了一条短信，问这套衣服合适吗？着装要求是什么来着？是真的很正式，还是我可以穿得随意一点？看，现在听着，安吉，如果你在我婚礼当天早上发短信问我一个问题，那没关系。但你知道吗？我不会那样做。这就是区别。最好的朋友可以被原谅。最好的朋友确实可以被原谅，但他们也应该懂事。是的。给其他婚礼客人发短信。你知道有人要去。给你最可靠的、保存了邀请函的朋友发短信。给你认识的婚礼派对上的朋友发短信。是的。那是他们的工作。让
the bride and groom alone. Okay. We could. really go off on that. I mean, listen, clearly, it meant so much to us. We moved it up to the top of the show. Yeah. We didn't even wait to get to that scene. I know. All right, let's do some fast facts. Fast fact number one, this episode is going to kick off a major story arc for Jim, in which he becomes the co-manager of the Scranton branch. Now, this is also going to signal a wardrobe change for Jim. Did you notice? Boob-do-boo-boo! Wardrobe change. Jim wears a jacket instead of his usual shirt and tie.
新郎新娘安静点。好吧。我们真的可以就此展开讨论。我的意思是，听着，很明显，这对我们意义重大。我们把它放到了节目的最前面。是的。我们甚至没有等到那一幕。我知道。好吧，让我们做一些快速事实。快速事实一，这一集将开启吉姆的一个主要故事线，他将成为斯克兰顿分部的联合经理。现在，这也将标志着吉姆的服装变化。你注意到了吗？服装变化。吉姆穿了一件夹克，而不是他通常的衬衫和领带。
Not just any jacket, a suit. Yeah. This is going to continue while he is co-manager. I guess jacket means you take things seriously. Look at Pam when she become a salesperson. They're the jacket couple now. We are. We're so cute.
不仅仅是任何夹克，是一套西装。是的。这将在他担任联合经理期间持续下去。我想夹克意味着你认真对待事情。看看帕姆成为销售员的时候。他们现在是夹克夫妇了。我们是。我们太可爱了。
You know how Dwight wore his long sleeves for Charles Minor? Yeah. These are ways that our wardrobe department can really, you know, signal story. telling. I think it's very cool and I wanted to give them a shout out. Love it. Loved our wardrobe department. I loved that fast fact. Thank you, Ange. Fast fact number two. This episode is a very interesting pairing as part of its B story. This feels like one of those assignments that we've heard about the taking of the two people, Dwight and Toby. When have we had a Dwight Toby huge storyline? I thought the same thing. They were on a card and they got sent off to the writer's
你知道德怀特是怎么为查尔斯·迈纳穿长袖的吗？是的。这些是我们的服装部门真正可以，你知道，发出故事信号的方式。我觉得这很酷，我想给他们点个赞。喜欢它。喜欢我们的服装部门。我喜欢那个快速事实。谢谢你，安吉。快速事实二。这一集作为其B故事的一部分，是一个非常有趣的配对。这感觉就像我们听说过的关于带走那两个人的任务，德怀特和托比。我们什么时候有过德怀特和托比的巨大故事线？我也这么想。他们在一张卡片上，然后被送到了编剧那里
Now, this B-Story was also ranked number seven on Screen Rant's Best B Plots. Do you know what was number one? No. Dwight's concussion. Oh, with Pam. Yeah. I did love that one. So incidentally, while Paul Lieberstein was starring in this very popular B story,
现在，这个B故事在Screen Rant的最佳B情节中排名第七。你知道第一名是什么吗？不知道。德怀特的脑震荡。哦，和帕姆一起。是的。我确实喜欢那一个。所以顺便说一句，当保罗·利伯斯坦在这一非常受欢迎的B故事中担任主角时，
he was also our sole showrunner for this season, season six. In season five, he shared that title with Gensilada, but at this point, point, Jen was starting to develop some other projects, so she took a step back in season six. She was a consulting producer. She worked three days a week. So Paul, our showrunner, was starring in this episode. I don't know. It just amazes me how he juggled it all. I mean, I feel like he was living there for a bit. Do you think he ever slept there? I feel like maybe at least once. We should ask them. We should ask. Now, fast fact number three, Angela, I am handing over to you. What would you like to tell us?
他也是我们这一季，第六季的唯一剧集主管。在第五季中，他与詹·西拉达分享了这个头衔，但此时，詹开始开发其他项目，所以她在第六季退后了一步。她是咨询制片人。她每周工作三天。所以保罗，我们的剧集主管，在这一集中担任主角。我不知道。他如何处理这一切让我感到惊讶。我的意思是，我觉得他有一段时间住在那里。你觉得他曾经在那里睡过吗？我觉得也许至少一次。我们应该问问他们。我们应该问问。现在，快速事实三，安吉拉，我交给你了。你想告诉我们什么？
I would like to talk about the deleted scenes for this episode. I am titling this fast fact because I guess I titled my fast facts. Oh. I'm titling my fast fact. Stay with me. Long, long, long, long. Oh. Long, long, long, long.
我想谈谈这一集的删减片段。我给这个快速事实起个标题，因为我想我给我的快速事实起了标题。哦。我正在给我的快速事实起标题。跟我一起。长，长，长，长。哦。长，长，长，长。
Should I be titling my fast facts? No. I think we're all fine, not too. You guys, this episode was a very long script. Oh. And a lot of our scripts came in very long, but I just thought this one really highlights how much didn't make it in that was written on the page. And I wanted to share that with you. Okay. It's a little insight, you guys, into the deleted scenes of an episode of the office. So I was training emails with Randy Cordray, and he said that there was so much material for our episodes that our editor's first cuts were usually about 45 minutes long. And we had to narrow that down to 21 minutes and 30 seconds to broadcast. the show. So they would cut more than half. Exactly. That brings me to this script. Jenna, I looked. The shooting draft was 41 pages. Okay, so it's usually a page equals a minute. We've talked about that
我应该给我的快速事实起标题吗？不。我觉得我们都很好，不用。伙计们，这一集的剧本非常长。哦。我们的很多剧本都很长，但我只是觉得这一集真正突出了有多少写在纸上的内容没有被拍出来。我想和你们分享一下。好的。这是一个小见解，伙计们，关于《办公室》一集的删减片段。所以我正在和兰迪·科德雷交换电子邮件，他说我们的剧集有太多的素材，我们的编辑的第一剪辑通常有45分钟长。我们必须将其缩减到21分30秒才能播出。节目。所以他们会剪掉一半以上。正是如此。这让我想到了这个剧本。珍娜，我看了。拍摄草稿有41页。好的，通常一页等于一分钟。我们之前谈过这个
before. Right. So they were going to have to edit out more than half the script. I went to the shooting draft and I read the shooting draft as I watched the episode that was broadcast and there were six talking heads that never made it in, eight full scenes. that never made it. And then five scenes were actually extended and longer than what made it onto the screen. And I was trading emails with Randy, and he brought up a great, great note, which is the whole Dwight and Toby Runner, as well as some of the Michael Andy Runner really had to be cut for this episode. And there are elements that didn't make it in that would have really kind of explained a little bit more what was happening. And I'm going to share some of those as we go.
。对。所以他们将不得不剪掉一半以上的剧本。我看了拍摄草稿，我在观看播出的那一集时阅读了拍摄草稿，有六个对着镜头说话的片段从未出现，八个完整的场景从未出现。然后有五个场景实际上被扩展了，比屏幕上出现的更长。我正在和兰迪交换电子邮件，他提出了一个非常非常好的注意点，那就是整个德怀特和托比的支线，以及一些迈克尔和安迪的支线确实必须为这一集剪掉。而且有一些没有出现的元素，如果保留的话，真的会解释更多正在发生的事情。随着节目的进行，我会分享其中一些。
Wow. This episode was almost like two A stories to me. Yes, exactly. Exactly. But if you think about it, I mean, six talking heads, eight whole scenes. Eight whole scenes. Wow. Right? Yeah. But you're going to give us the dish. I'm going to give you the dish. You're going to spill the tea. Is that what it is? Spill the tea? Do you spill the tea? I think you spill the tea and you serve the dish. And you give the scoop. What else? What's another one? I don't know. That's my fast fact. That just shows you what we had to do every week to trim it to network broadcast. I enjoyed this top of show. Should we go to a break? And when we come back, we will spill the tea and give the dish and the tell the things. We'll tell all the things. All right. Right. This episode starts with a cold open between Michael and Oscar. Michael has called Oscar into his office for advice on an upcoming medical procedure.
哇。这一集对我来说几乎就像两个A故事。是的，正是如此。正是如此。但如果你想一想，我的意思是，六个对着镜头说话的片段，八个完整的场景。八个完整的场景。哇。对吧？是的。但你会给我们爆料。我会给你们爆料。你会泄露秘密。是这样吗？泄露秘密？你泄露秘密吗？我想你泄露秘密，然后你端上菜。你提供独家新闻。还有什么？还有另一个吗？我不知道。这就是我的快速事实。这只是向你展示了我们每周必须做些什么来将其修剪到网络广播。我喜欢这个节目的开头。我们要去休息一下吗？当我们回来时，我们将泄露秘密，提供独家新闻，并讲述那些事情。我们会讲述所有的事情。好吧。对。这一集以迈克尔和奥斯卡之间的冷开场开始。迈克尔把奥斯卡叫进他的办公室，就即将进行的医疗程序寻求建议。
And Oscar is concerned. He's like, Michael, are you okay? What's going on? Michael reveals it's a colonoscopy and wonders if in Oscar's experience, there's anything he can do to make it more pleasurable for himself or the doctor. And Oscar, of course, walks out of Michael's office. Yes. Now, I always love scenes between Steve and Oscar.
奥斯卡很担心。他说，迈克尔，你还好吗？怎么了？迈克尔透露这是结肠镜检查，并想知道在奥斯卡的经验中，有什么他可以做的能让自己或医生更愉快的事情。奥斯卡当然走出了迈克尔的办公室。是的。现在，我总是喜欢史蒂夫和奥斯卡之间的场景。
They are so good together. They're a good comedy duo. This scene made me cringe. Yeah. But Oscar's performance is a... So good. Oh my God. Oscar's amazing.
他们在一起太棒了。他们是一个很好的喜剧二人组。这一幕让我感到尴尬。是的。但奥斯卡的表演是……太棒了。天哪。奥斯卡太棒了。
I caught an improv moment. Oh. Yeah. So it's not in the script. I went to the shooting draft. There's this moment where Oscar says, what's the procedure, if you don't mind me asking? And he scoches his chair real close to Michael's desk.
我捕捉到了一个即兴表演的时刻。哦。是的。所以它不在剧本里。我看了拍摄草稿。有这样一个时刻，奥斯卡说，如果你不介意我问的话，程序是什么？他把椅子挪得离迈克尔的桌子很近。
Oscar Nunez came up with that sort of physical improv in the moment to sort of, you know, try to bond with Michael, right? What's happening, Michael? I thought that was just smart acting. Well, Steve and Oscar have a very similar improvisation style. and it's based on small details and slow timing. Like patience. Pace, all of it.
奥斯卡·努涅斯在那个时刻想出了那种身体即兴表演，为了，你知道，试图与迈克尔建立联系，对吧？发生了什么，迈克尔？我觉得那只是聪明的表演。好吧，史蒂夫和奥斯卡有非常相似的即兴表演风格。它是基于小细节和缓慢的节奏。比如耐心。节奏，所有的一切。
Yeah. Well, I have another background catch in this scene. Okay. I caught Meredith at front reception talking to Pam, and I couldn't help but wonder, is this a Kate Jenna Faky spreadsheet conversation moment? You know what, lady? What?
是的。好吧，我在这一幕中还有另一个背景捕捉。好的。我捕捉到梅雷迪思在前台和帕姆说话，我不禁想，这是凯特和珍娜的虚假电子表格对话时刻吗？你知道吗，女士？什么？
She's talking to Erin. Oh, no. Yeah. And you know what? I saw Kate at reception, And the first thing I thought was, oh, my God, or me and Kate doing our bit? And then I realized, it's not me. I thought it was me, too.
她在和艾琳说话。哦，不。是的。你知道吗？我在前台看到了凯特，我脑子里想的第一件事是，哦，天哪，我和凯特在做我们的表演吗？然后我意识到，那不是我。我也以为是我。
Oh, my gosh. It's Erin. That just shows you, even though we know the show, we're rewatching it, we were there. I will always think of Pam as that front reception. It's true. You know, Pam spends half of the series as not a receptionist, and yet I still think of her as the receptionist. and people regard me as the receptionist when they meet me. Yeah.
哦，天哪。是艾琳。这只是向你展示，即使我们知道这个节目，我们正在重温它，我们当时在那里。我总是会把帕姆想成那个前台。这是真的。你知道，帕姆有一半的系列时间不是接待员，然而我仍然认为她是接待员。人们在见到我时也把我视为接待员。是的。
Yeah. Oh, I guess I did. I know. I did too. Well, as the episode starts, there is a deleted scene, you guys, that would have set up how truly overwhelmed Michael was. And I thought it was kind of important. I want to share it with you.
是的。哦，我想我确实是。我知道。我也一样。好吧，当这一集开始时，有一个删减的场景，伙计们，它本来会设定迈克尔是多么真正地不知所措。我觉得它有点重要。我想和你们分享一下。
In the shooting draft, it says we're inside Michael's office. Michael is looking slightly more haggard than usual. He sits in his office with Aaron. She is just handing him post-it notes. We see the perimeter of Michael's desktop monitor is completely covered with multi-colored post-it notes. And then Aaron says Bill Seedman from Buffalo and hands Michael a post-it note. He puts yet another one on his computer. Michael says, thank you.
在拍摄草稿中，它说我们在迈克尔的办公室里。迈克尔看起来比平时稍微憔悴一些。他坐在办公室里和艾琳在一起。她只是递给他便利贴。我们看到迈克尔桌面显示器的周边完全被五颜六色的便利贴覆盖了。然后艾琳说来自布法罗的比尔·西德曼，并递给迈克尔一张便利贴。他把另一张贴在电脑上。迈克尔说，谢谢。
And then Aaron hands him another post-it note. And then Aaron says, Angela is still waiting for you to approve the new billing rates from Buffalo. And in the script, it says Michael lets out an exasperated yelp. He stares at all of the post-it note. notes. Lady, I have to tell you, at 12 minutes one second, there is a scene between David Wallace and Michael in his office, and in the foreground is half of Michael's computer monitor. And I was like, why are there all these sticky notes on Michael's computer monitor? I took a picture of it to show you. And here you have answered the question for me. Well, here it is. This is what it looks like in the
然后艾琳又递给他一张便利贴。然后艾琳说，安吉拉还在等你批准布法罗的新账单费率。在剧本中，它说迈克尔发出了一声恼怒的尖叫。他盯着所有的便利贴。女士，我必须告诉你，在12分01秒，大卫·华莱士和迈克尔在他的办公室里有一场戏，前景是迈克尔电脑显示器的一半。我当时想，为什么迈克尔的电脑显示器上有这么多便利贴？我拍了一张照片给你们看。在这里你已经为我回答了这个问题。好吧，就在这里。这就是它在
deleted scenes. I took a picture as well. I'll put a picture as well. put it in stories. Oh, that's the full monitor. You have full monitor. I have full monitor. And you guys, I took a picture of my own desktop computer. Is it very similar to Michael Scott's computer? I'm going to put a side by side. Mine is not as bad as Michael's, but clearly Michael and I have the same way of keeping track of things. I have post-its all around my computer. As you know, Jenna, so I couldn't help but crack up. But the scene goes on to sort of explain that Michael is really overwhelmed because of Buffalo closing, they've absorbed all the new clients. And it's part of the reason why David Wallace is there. Wow. Well, I feel like that scene would have been very helpful in terms of setup. Yeah. But instead, the episode opens with Michael walking out of his office with David Wallace. And it's just one line. One line. David is like, can I get the rundown of the Buffalo clients by Sunday night? Yeah. But you don't know that Michael is like being buried in a sea of Post-it notes from all these other new clients.
删减片段中的样子。我也拍了一张照片。我也会放一张照片。把它放在故事里。哦，那是完整的显示器。你有完整的显示器。我有完整的显示器。伙计们，我也拍了我自己的台式电脑的照片。它和迈克尔·斯科特的电脑很像吗？我要做一个并排对比。我的没有迈克尔的那么糟糕，但很明显迈克尔和我保持记录的方式是一样的。我的电脑周围都有便利贴。如你所知，珍娜，所以我忍不住大笑起来。但这一幕继续解释说，迈克尔因为布法罗的关闭而真正不知所措，他们吸收了所有的新客户。这也是大卫·华莱士在那里的一部分原因。哇。好吧，我觉得那一幕在设定方面会非常有帮助。是的。但相反，这一集以迈克尔和戴维·华莱士走出他的办公室开始。而且只有一行台词。一行台词。大卫说，我能在周日晚上拿到布法罗客户的摘要吗？是的。但你不知道迈克尔正被所有这些其他新客户的便利贴海洋所淹没。
Well, Michael says he will get that rundown done by Sunday night. And David Wallace is like, great. And he's like, well, I mean, I'm going to put it in the mail on Sunday. So you should get it by Wednesday. But I also thought, this can't be an email. You have to physically mail this rundown? Have you seen Michael's computer? Michael's computer is just basically a shelf for Post-it notes.
好吧，迈克尔说他会在周日晚上完成那个摘要。大卫·华莱士说，太好了。他说，好吧，我的意思是，我会在周日把它寄出去。所以你应该在周三收到。但我还想，这不可能是电子邮件吗？你必须物理邮寄这个摘要？你见过迈克尔的电脑吗？迈克尔的电脑基本上只是便利贴的架子。
True. It's not a working device. Unless you want to watch a YouTube video, that's all that happens. Well, now Wallace is going to take Jim into the conference room for a meeting to which Michael is not invited. I have a question for Jim. What? Jim, why, why, why? Would you take this meeting with David?
真的。它不是一个工作设备。除非你想看YouTube视频，否则这就是全部。好吧，现在华莱士要把吉姆带进会议室开会，迈克尔没有被邀请。我有一个关于吉姆的问题。什么？吉姆，为什么，为什么，为什么？你会和戴维开这个会吗？
In Scranton. In Scranton. I thought the same thing. Why not say, David, can I meet you after work? Can I come to New York? Yeah, can we have lunch and make up an excuse like clearly everyone else does? at Dunderman Flynn make up an excuse at lunch that you're going to see a client. Of course Michael's going to spiral. Come on, Jim. You know better. I thought the same thing too. But it was clear that
在斯克兰顿。在斯克兰顿。我也这么想。为什么不说，戴维，我能在下班后见你吗？我能去纽约吗？是的，我们能吃午饭并找个借口吗，就像邓德·米夫林的其他人显然做的那样？在午餐时找个借口说你要去见客户。迈克尔当然会失控。得了吧，吉姆。你应该更懂事。我也这么想。但很明显
David came to Scranton because he had a lot of business to do. So he's consolidating, but I think Jim should have been more proactive. Well, I have a background catch for this little scene. Angela. Give it to me. I love a background catch. At one minute, 58 seconds, there is a book on Michael's credenza, and it is very prominent. And it is titled, First, Break All the Rules, What the World's Greatest Managers Do Differently. Now, I assumed this was a prop book that Phil Shea created. Is it a faky book? It is a really book. Come on. This is a real book. And here is the book's description. In this longtime management bestseller, Gallup presents the remarkable findings of its massive, in-depth study of great managers. Some were in leadership positions. Others were frontline supervisors.
戴维来到斯克兰顿是因为他有很多业务要做。所以他正在整合，但我认为吉姆应该更主动一些。好吧，我为这个小场景有一个背景捕捉。安吉拉。给我。我喜欢背景捕捉。在1分58秒，迈克尔的餐具柜上有一本书，它非常显眼。它的标题是，《首先，打破所有规则，世界上最伟大的经理人有何不同》。现在，我以为这是菲尔·谢伊制作的道具书。这是一本假书吗？这是一本真正的书。得了吧。这是一本真正的书。这是这本书的描述。在这本长期的管理畅销书中，盖洛普展示了其对伟大经理人的大规模、深入研究的非凡发现。有些处于领导职位。其他人是前线主管。
Some were in Fortune 500 companies. Others were key players in small entrepreneurial firms. They all excelled at turning each individual employee's talent into high performance. Now, according to a review, this study, this analysis, consisted of interviews with 80,000 management. 80,000? Yeah. In order to write this book, they talked to 80,000 managers that were, like, determined to be great managers. Wow. Here are three observations from the book. Okay. There are many, but here's three. Number one, people don't quit their companies. They quit their bosses. Oh, true. True. All the jobs I've quit have been because I hated my boss. I mean, I did quit a job just because I hated the job. But your boss was was great. Yeah, I liked my boss. Oh, but I hated the job. Okay. Sorry, it happens, guys. Well, number two, one of the signs of a great manager is the ability to describe in detail the unique talent of each
有些在财富500强公司。其他人是小型创业公司中的关键参与者。他们都擅长将每个员工的才能转化为高绩效。现在，根据评论，这项研究，这项分析，包括对80,000名管理人员的采访。80,000？是的。为了写这本书，他们采访了80,000名被确定为伟大经理人的经理。哇。这是书中的三个观察结果。好的。有很多，但这是三个。第一，人们不会辞职离开公司。他们辞职离开老板。哦，真的。真的。我辞掉的所有工作都是因为我讨厌我的老板。我的意思是，我确实辞掉了一份工作只是因为我讨厌这份工作。但你的老板很棒。是的，我喜欢我的老板。哦，但我讨厌这份工作。好的。抱歉，伙计们，这发生了。好吧，第二，伟大经理人的标志之一是能够详细描述每个
employee, what drives them, how they think, and how each one builds relationships. This also sounds like what it is to be a good partner. I mean, that reminded me of what it is to be a great director. Lee is a director, my husband, and he's often said, like, you have to have a different directing style with each actor, because some actors like a lot of notes and some don't, and some need a lot of pep talk, and others hate that. He's like, so, like, the first day on the job, your job is to figure out just, like, how to talk to each different person. Like learning everyone's strengths and quirks. Yeah, exactly. And finally, I thought this was very, very, Very interesting.
员工的独特才能，什么驱动他们，他们如何思考，以及每个人如何建立关系。这也听起来像是一个好的合作伙伴。我的意思是，这让我想起了成为一名伟大的导演是什么感觉。李是一名导演，我的丈夫，他经常说，你必须对每个演员有不同的导演风格，因为有些演员喜欢很多笔记，有些不喜欢，有些需要很多鼓励，而其他人讨厌那样。他说，所以，上班的第一天，你的工作就是弄清楚如何与每个人交谈。就像学习每个人的优点和怪癖。是的，正是如此。最后，我觉得这非常非常非常有趣。
A great manager knows the difference between skills, knowledge, and weakness. Hmm. Meaning like, just because someone doesn't know how to do something that's not a weakness, maybe that's just a lack of skill or lack of knowledge. But if they have knowledge and they're not doing it right, well, then that would be a weakness. Yeah. So I have to say, I kind of thought that Michael Scott was good at number two and three. the list. Like, he really knows everybody really well in his company. He knows how to motivate them.
一位伟大的经理人知道技能、知识和弱点之间的区别。嗯。意思是，仅仅因为某人不知道如何做某事，那不是弱点，也许那只是缺乏技能或缺乏知识。但如果他们有知识而他们没有做对，好吧，那将是一个弱点。是的。所以我必须说，我有点认为迈克尔·斯科特在名单上的第二和第三点做得很好。比如，他真的非常了解公司里的每个人。他知道如何激励他们。
I thought maybe he had read this book on his credenza. He definitely has number two because the way he introduces a person when someone new is in the office, it's very specific. He knows everyone very intimately. He does. It doesn't take Michael long to start spiraling about Jim and David in the conference room. He says he's not worried, but he corners Pam pretty quickly. He does. He does. He escorts her the three steps to her desk, but she's not telling him anything. She clearly knows why Jim is meeting with David. This scene was so hard to get through Angela. As soon as Steve would kneel down next to my desk, I would start laughing.
我想也许他在他的餐具柜上读过这本书。他绝对有第二点，因为当办公室里有新人时，他介绍人的方式非常具体。他非常亲密地了解每个人。他确实了解。迈克尔不需要太长时间就开始因为吉姆和戴维在会议室里而失控。他说他不担心，但他很快就把帕姆逼到了角落。他确实。他确实。他护送她走了三步到她的桌子，但她什么也没告诉他。她显然知道吉姆为什么要见戴维。这一幕很难熬过去，安吉拉。史蒂夫一跪在我的桌子旁边，我就开始笑。
Just the sincerity with which he would kneel. But then when he would say that my lies would pass through my breast milk and make my unborn baby a liar, it was like really hard. It was very, very funny. I really liked it when he said, well, why did you say good luck? And you were like, that's not like me. I don't know. I don't sure why I would say that.
仅仅是他跪下的那种真诚。但当他说我的谎言会通过我的母乳传递，让我未出生的孩子成为一个骗子时，这真的很难。这非常非常有趣。我真的很喜欢他说，好吧，你为什么要说祝你好运？而你当时说，那不像我。我不知道。我不确定我为什么要那样说。
I'm not very superstitious. I was like, what is Pam doing? She's so bad at lying. I would like to point out in this scene. I think I'm doing some really wonderful prop work. I am filling a binder. Yeah, you're very busy. With some sheets of paper.
我不怎么迷信。我当时想，帕姆在做什么？她撒谎太糟糕了。我想在这一幕中指出。我想我做了一些非常棒的道具工作。我正在装订一个活页夹。是的，你很忙。用一些纸张。
Yeah. Yeah. That was my idea. I thought this would feel like more. significant than just carrying some papers from the copier and sitting down. I was like, could you get me a binder? And I could be like making a binder. Anything to not be answering his questions? I liked my choice. I like it too. Well, this is going to start the Dwight Toby Runner, aka, are they mom detectives? This whole storyline is 100% a case that mom detectives would take.
是的。是的。那是我的主意。我觉得这会感觉比仅仅从复印机拿一些纸然后坐下更有意义。我当时想，你能给我一个活页夹吗？我可以像在制作一个活页夹一样。任何事情都比回答他的问题要好？我喜欢我的选择。我也喜欢它。好吧，这将开启德怀特和托比的支线，也就是，他们是妈妈侦探吗？整个故事情节100%是妈妈侦探会接手的案件。
A hundred percent. Yeah, a fraudulent workers' compensation claim. Possible fraudulent. Possible fraudulent. Dwight is in the break room and he overhears Daryl telling Toby how he broke his ankle and he's got a doctor's note and, you know, Toby's fine with it. And Dwight is like, no, no, no, no, no. Red flags. I'll tell you the only thing I saw in this scene was it three minutes, 18 seconds. Is it a stuffed animal?
百分之百。是的。欺诈性的工伤赔偿索赔。可能的欺诈。可能的欺诈。德怀特在休息室，他无意中听到达里尔告诉托比他是如何摔断脚踝的，他有医生的证明，而且，你知道，托比对此没问题。而德怀特是，不，不，不，不，不。危险信号。我告诉你，我在这一幕中看到的唯一一件事是3分18秒。是一个毛绒玩具吗？
The stuffed dog wearing a Toby shirt? Wearing a maroon sweater. What the heck? It totally took me out. out of the scene for a minute. I was like, where did this stuffed animal come from? Why does it say Toby? What is happening? But wait, just wait. I have a picture that I took, lady, to show you, even though you saw this dog, too. Did you zoom in on it? Just look at it next to Paul. Just look at it. Look at Toby dog next to real Toby. Look at it. They are frowning the same.
那个穿着托比衬衫的毛绒狗？穿着栗色毛衣。这到底是什么？它完全让我从场景中分心了一分钟。我当时想，这个毛绒玩具是从哪里来的？为什么它写着托比？发生了什么？但等等，等着。我拍了一张照片，女士，给你们看，即使你也看到了这只狗。你放大看了吗？看看它在保罗旁边的样子。看看它。看看托比狗在真正的托比旁边。看看它。它们皱眉的样子是一样的。
They're in the same color scheme. Look at it. Oh my God. Do you think this is like a writer's joke? A fleshy joke? I feel like someone saw this stuffed dog and they were like, oh my God, it's Toby. And they put a Toby shirt on it and then they put it on his desk. I mean, what is that? I need the story of that. We need to dig deeper. You have to post this picture. It's not in the script. It's not in the script. This Toby dog. It's all I could see. Well, I guess Dwight brings up enough suspicion that Toby's like, all right, maybe we should check this out, right? And he said, plus, He's always been a fan of these hard-boiled detective novels. Well, we got a fan question from Alice R. in Italy, who says around four minutes, 30 seconds, Toby has a sheet behind him that lists all of the HR representatives from all the Dundermifflin branches. So besides Toby and Holly, who are these other people? Are these made up names? Alice also noted that Holly is wrongly associated with the Utica branch instead of the Nashua branch. She was really looking. I am impressed.
它们在同一个配色方案中。看看它。哦，天哪。你觉得这是编剧的玩笑吗？一个肉欲的玩笑？我觉得有人看到了这只毛绒狗，他们当时想，哦，天哪，它是托比。他们给它穿上了一件托比衬衫，然后把它放在了他的桌子上。我的意思是，那是什么？我需要那个故事。我们需要深入挖掘。你必须发布这张照片。它不在剧本里。它不在剧本里。这只托比狗。这是我能看到的全部。好吧，我想德怀特提出了足够的怀疑，以至于托比觉得，好吧，也许我们应该查一下，对吧？他说，加上，他一直很喜欢这些硬汉侦探小说。好吧，我们收到了来自意大利爱丽丝·R的粉丝提问，她说在4分30秒左右，托比身后有一张纸，列出了所有邓德·米夫林分部的HR代表。所以除了托比和霍莉，这些人是谁？这些是编造的名字吗？爱丽丝还指出，霍莉被错误地与尤蒂卡分部联系在一起，而不是纳舒厄分部。她真的在看。我印象深刻。
I am too. Alice, here's the thing. I zoomed in on this, and it was a little fuzzy. I found it very hard to read, and I really looked at it. I don't know if this is my sign that I need to go get a new pair of glasses. Here's what I could read on the piece of paper. Number one, yes, Holly is listed as Utica. Good catch.
我也是。爱丽丝，事情是这样的。我放大了这个，它有点模糊。我发现它很难读，我真的看了它。我不知道这是否是我需要去配一副新眼镜的信号。这是我在那张纸上能读到的内容。第一，是的，霍莉被列为尤蒂卡。好眼力。
Also, her name is listed as Hollis, P. Flacks. Jenny O'Keefe is one of the names on the list. Aw, Jenny! She was our second AD. That's right. I could not tell what branch she was associated with. It was too blurry for me. But Nick Carbone...
此外，她的名字被列为霍利斯·P·弗拉克斯。珍妮·奥基夫是名单上的名字之一。啊，珍妮！她是我们的第二助理导演。那是对的。我看不出她与哪个分部有关。对我来说太模糊了。但是尼克·卡伯恩……
Oh, Nick our boom operator. Was listed as the Buffalo Branch, HR representative. And Debbie Pierce. Debbie? From hair and makeup. Debbie did hair. Debbie was listed as the Nashville branch, HR representative. And then when there were three more names, I could not make up.
哦，尼克我们的吊杆操作员。被列为布法罗分部的HR代表。还有黛比·皮尔斯。黛比？来自发型和化妆。黛比做了头发。黛比被列为纳舒厄分部的HR代表。然后当还有三个名字时，我无法编造
their last names or their branches, but they were Shelly, Kim, and Chris. We had several people with those names, and I could not make out the last names. Okay. But good catch, Alice, that was really fun for me to see all those names on that sheet. And that's who they were. I love that. I love how set dressing would put the names of our crew all over the set. I know. Well, Jenna, I had to know what a hard-boiled detective was. Oh, okay. I mean, especially if we're going to be mom detectives, I feel like I need to know the genre. Yeah. So this is what it says on the internet.
他们的姓氏或他们的分部，但他们是雪莉、金和克里斯。我们有几个叫这些名字的人，我无法辨认出姓氏。好的。但好眼力，爱丽丝，看到那张纸上的所有名字对我来说真的很有趣。这就是他们是谁。我喜欢那个。我喜欢布景装饰如何把我们工作人员的名字放在布景各处。我知道。好吧，珍娜，我必须知道什么是硬汉侦探。哦，好的。我的意思是，特别是如果我们要做妈妈侦探，我觉得我需要了解这个流派。是的。所以这是互联网上说的。
It's a literary genre that shares some of its characters and settings with crime fiction, especially detective fiction, are noir fiction. And hard-boiled means to be devoid of sentimentality, tough, being a detective, or story featuring a tough, unsinimental protagonist, a matter-of-fact attitudes towards violence, hard-headed, and practical. Oh. very un-Tobie-like. Yeah.
它是一种文学流派，与犯罪小说，特别是侦探小说或黑色小说共享其部分角色和背景。而硬汉意味着缺乏感伤，强硬，成为一名侦探，或以强硬、不感伤的主角为特色的故事，对暴力采取实事求是的态度，顽固且务实。哦。非常不像托比。是的。
So to be a hard-boiled detective, this is like Toby's version of being a superhero. That's right. Wow. I know. Well, now Michael is going to interrupt Jim's meeting with David Wallace. He's just going to burst into the conference room while on the phone. I have his fake phone call conversations. Please.
所以成为一名硬汉侦探，这就像托比成为超级英雄的版本。那是对的。哇。我知道。好吧，现在迈克尔要打断吉姆和戴维·华莱士的会议。他只是要闯入会议室，同时在打电话。我有他假装打电话的对话。请。
His first one, as he walks in, he says, uh-huh, uh-huh. Well, if he doesn't like it, you can tell that SOB that he's fired. Sorry, I'm going into a meeting right now. I will. I love you too. Bye. Who's he talking to? Who's he talking to?
他走进去时的第一个，他说，嗯哼，嗯哼。好吧，如果他不喜欢，你可以告诉那个混蛋他被解雇了。抱歉，我现在要开会了。我会的。我也爱你。再见。他在和谁说话？他在和谁说话？
And when he leaves, this is his other faky phone call. Oh, this call waiting. Yeah. Uh-huh. Well, you tell the mayor he just lost six votes. This tactic of bursting into the room talking on the phone reminded me a little bit of my strategy of walking up to famous people laughing. I have to say. I thought maybe.
当他离开时，这是他的另一个假电话。哦，这个呼叫等待。是的。嗯哼。好吧，你告诉市长他刚刚失去了六张选票。这种闯入房间打电话的策略让我想起了一点我走向名人并大笑的策略。我必须说。我想也许。
This is Michael's way into a meeting. Yeah. Meeting people. So now Creed and Michael are sort of peering into the conference room together from some file cabinets. First of all, Creed just always makes me laugh. I love him. I love every time he is on screen. What I also love about the character Creed is that he is the last person you ever want to
这是迈克尔进入会议的方式。是的。认识人。所以现在克里德和迈克尔正从一些文件柜一起窥视会议室。首先，克里德总是让我发笑。我爱他。我爱他出现在屏幕上的每一次。我也喜欢克里德这个角色的原因是，他是你最不想
make you feel better about a situation. True. And so the fact that they partnered him next to Michael while Michael is worried about what's happening in the conference room is so perfect. During this, Steve is flipping through the yellow pages. Oh, no. What did you see? Do you remember the yellow pages?
让你对情况感觉更好的人。真的。所以他们把他和迈克尔配对，而迈克尔担心会议室里正在发生什么，这太完美了。在此期间，史蒂夫正在翻阅黄页。哦，不。你看到了什么？你还记得黄页吗？
Of course. You used to get a big one in the mail. Yeah. Does this happen anymore? I think the yellow pages are online now, but I think in some places they still print them. Yeah, you used to. still get a hard copy, I think. Well, I don't get one. I feel like I got one a few years ago. I don't know. Do young ins know what the yellow pages are? Let your fingers do the walking. Do they know?
当然。你以前在邮件里会收到一大本。是啊。现在还有这种事吗？我想黄页现在都在网上了，但我认为在某些地方他们还在印刷。是啊，你以前确实还能收到纸质版，我想。嗯，我没收到过。我觉得我几年前收到过一本。我不知道。年轻人知道什么是黄页吗？让你的手指去散步（黄页广告语）。他们知道吗？
I doubt it. You know what? We should show our kids a yellow page. Here, guys, for any of you out there who are young and are like, what are the yellow pages? So every year you would get a phone book. First of all, you would get white pages and that would list and name and address. Yeah, it was like an alphabetical list of everyone in your city. And I remember getting it as a kid and like looking us up and being like, there we are. Ours always had like a little star or circle by someone we knew. Like my mom would have gone through and like made little markings. Oh yeah, or you earmark it. Yeah.
我怀疑。你知道吗？我们应该给我们的孩子看看黄页。嘿，伙计们，对于你们这些年轻人，如果你们在想，什么是黄页？那么，每年你都会收到一本电话簿。首先，你会收到白页，上面会列出姓名和地址。是啊，就像是你所在城市每个人的字母顺序列表。我记得小时候收到它，然后查我们自己，心想，我们在这儿。我们的那本上总是有某位我们认识的人旁边有个小星星或圆圈。就像我妈妈会翻阅它，然后做些小标记。哦，是的，或者你会折角。是啊。
Well, the Yellow Pages was a directory of all of the businesses in your area. And they were listed alphabetically by the type of business. Right, like florist. Yes, if you needed an electrician. You looked in the electrician section. And different businesses might take out ads so that their listing was bigger or flashier like a half page. Yeah, and that's why a lot of businesses would put the letter A somewhere in the name, like awesome plumbers. Because then they would be at the top of the list. Yes. And then there were also the blue pages, which is a government directory. I never got a blue page. I never got a blue page. I never heard of the blue pages. Well, they could be at your library. You could look in the blue pages if you needed to contact a government agency in your area. Like the water department for your city.
嗯，黄页是你所在地区所有企业的名录。它们按企业类型以字母顺序排列。对，比如花店。是的，如果你需要电工。你就在电工那一栏找。不同的企业可能会买广告，这样他们的列表就会更大或更显眼，比如半页。是啊，这就是为什么很多企业会在名字里加个字母A，比如“超棒水管工”（Awesome Plumbers）。因为这样他们就会排在列表的最前面。是的。然后还有蓝页，那是政府名录。我从来没收到过蓝页。我从来没收到过蓝页。我从没听说过蓝页。嗯，它们可能在你的图书馆里。如果你需要联系你所在地区的政府机构，你可以查阅蓝页。比如你所在城市的水务部门。
Yes. But when I saw the yellow pages, I got really nostalgic. And I was like, as a kid, I would flip through the yellow pages and look at the ads. Like, I would read the comics in the newspaper that we got every day at our house. Yeah, the funnies. The funnies. And, like, I would read the back of the cereal box at breakfast. because we didn't have smartphones or internet.
是的。但当我看到黄页时，我感到非常怀旧。我就想，小时候，我会翻阅黄页看广告。就像我会读我们每天送到家里的报纸上的漫画一样。是啊，滑稽漫画。滑稽漫画。而且，就像我吃早餐时会读麦片盒的背面一样。因为我们没有智能手机或互联网。
Right. I would flip through the Sears catalog, circling stuff. Oh, how great was it to get a catalog? I love a catalog. I still love a catalog. I do still love a catalog. Anyway, well, there you go for you, youngens. All the fun you missed out on.
对。我会翻阅西尔斯（Sears）目录，把东西圈出来。哦，收到目录有多棒啊？我喜欢目录。我仍然喜欢目录。我确实仍然喜欢目录。总之，好吧，这就是给你们这些年轻人的。你们错过的所有乐趣。
Anytime you want a breakdown of some old tech, just hit up these two middle-aged ladies, we'll tell you. Oh, now we have Pam's storyline. Yes, she's on the hunt for the art. RSVPs. She starts with Kelly. Kelly wants to know if Ryan is going to the wedding. She doesn't want to RSVP unless Ryan is going. Because it would be a waste of time. I mean, wait, that came out wrong. Right. I mean, what she's trying to say is that she would really like it if Ryan went because then she would go and she'd really like to be there to support Jim. Everything she said to you was like, it's a frenomy moment.
任何时候你想了解一些旧技术，就找这两位中年女士，我们会告诉你的。哦，现在我们有帕姆的故事线了。是的，她在寻找艺术品。回复邀请（RSVP）。她从凯利开始。凯利想知道瑞安是否会去参加婚礼。除非瑞安去，否则她不想回复。因为那会浪费时间。我是说，等等，那话说错了。对。我是说，她想表达的是，如果瑞安去的话，她会很高兴，因为那样她就会去，而且她真的很想去那里支持吉姆。她对你说的每一句话都像是一个“友敌”时刻。
We had a fan question from Heather B. in Victoria, British Columbia. At 5 minutes, 48 seconds, when Pam goes to Kelly's desk, there is a sign that says Kelly's nook. Oh. And there is. And, you know, before she had her little nameplate that said Kelly that she got in the Yankee swap. But this is a new sign. It says Kelly's nook. I love a nook. Heather B wondered if this was an addition from the scene. when she told Dwight to get out of her nook. Well, this scene is going to take us to a Pam talking head. And Pam and Jim have clearly done that thing. The destination wedding, you guys, if your friend has a destination wedding, it's because they're trying to rule out some people.
我们有一个来自不列颠哥伦比亚省维多利亚市希瑟·B的粉丝提问。在5分48秒时，当帕姆走到凯利的办公桌前，有一个牌子写着“凯利的角落”（Kelly's nook）。哦。确实有。而且，你知道，在那之前她有一个写着“凯利”的小名牌，那是她在“洋基交换”（Yankee swap）中得到的。但这是一个新牌子。上面写着“凯利的角落”。我喜欢“角落”这个词。希瑟·B想知道这是否是那个场景的补充，当时她告诉德怀特离开她的角落。嗯，这个场景将带我们进入帕姆的访谈。帕姆和吉姆显然已经做了那件事。目的地婚礼，伙计们，如果你的朋友举办目的地婚礼，那是因为他们想排除掉一些人。
I think that's true. Because you're allowed to have a smaller guest list if it's a destination wedding. That's right. You don't expect everyone to go with you to like a remote area or like a fancy vacation. I'm getting married on a boat. What? Well, it is revealed that Jim and Pam are getting married in Niagara Falls. Now, when we traded emails with Warren and Halstead about their episode, Cafe Disco,
我认为那是真的。因为如果是目的地婚礼，你可以有更小的宾客名单。没错。你不会指望每个人都和你一起去什么偏远地区或什么豪华度假地。我要在船上结婚。什么？嗯，据透露吉姆和帕姆要在尼亚加拉大瀑布结婚。现在，当我们和沃伦（Warren）与霍尔斯特德（Halstead）交换关于他们那集《咖啡迪斯科》（Cafe Disco）的邮件时，
Hallstead reminded me that in an earlier version of the script, Pam and Jim were going to get married in Paris. Oh, my gosh, I forgot that. Isn't that crazy? And they changed it to Niagara because they felt like Paris, number one, they thought it was a little bit too kind of on the nether. knows, romantic, maybe too much of a stretch budget-wise, and they thought Niagara Falls was perfect. I agree. I think that Paris just seems a little too big and too far away for who Jim and Pam are. I agree. Now, also speaking of Niagara Falls, we are not that far from these wedding episodes.
霍尔斯特德提醒我，在剧本的早期版本中，帕姆和吉姆要在巴黎结婚。哦，天哪，我忘了那个了。那不是很疯狂吗？他们把它改成了尼亚加拉，因为他们觉得巴黎，第一，他们认为这有点太……你知道，浪漫，预算上可能太吃力了，而且他们认为尼亚加拉大瀑布很完美。我同意。我认为巴黎对吉姆和帕姆来说显得有点太宏大、太遥远了。我同意。现在，说到尼亚加拉大瀑布，我们离这些婚礼剧集已经不远了。
And Randy shared with us that they were already heavily prepping that episode. like heavily. It's a big episode. We'll get there, but it's a big one. At six minutes 32 seconds, we got a fan question from Emily B. In Alabama, who said, Behind Pam on the file cabinet by Kelly's desk,
兰迪（Randy）和我们分享说，他们已经在为那一集做大量的准备工作了。非常大量。这是一集大制作。我们会讲到的，但这是一集很重要的剧集。在6分32秒，我们收到了来自阿拉巴马州艾米丽·B的粉丝提问，她说，在帕姆身后的凯利办公桌旁的文件柜上，
there is a Greater Scranton Chamber of Commerce business card from someone named Mary. I looked up the current board of directors, and apparently this person is no longer active, but I'm curious to know why were they represented on the show. Emily B, Mary at the Chamber of Commerce was like a huge help to our show. Yes, she's an unsung hero. Carrie Bennett shared all about her with us.
有一张来自一位名叫玛丽（Mary）的大斯克兰顿商会（Greater Scranton Chamber of Commerce）的名片。我查了当前的董事会成员，显然这个人已经不再活跃了，但我很好奇为什么他们会出现在节目中。艾米丽·B，商会的玛丽对我们的节目帮助巨大。是的，她是无名英雄。嘉莉·贝内特（Carrie Bennett）和我们分享了关于她的一切。
Yeah, if you remember in Carrie Bennett's interview, it was from a revisited episode, Carrie shared that she created a relationship with Mary, and Mary would help us get local treasures for the show, props, signs, pizza boxes. That is a great interview, by the way. If you guys haven't listened to it, our interview with Carrie Bennett, who was the wardrobe designer for the office for the first four seasons. And she really was like groundbreaking in what she brought to the show. And the relationship with Mary was one of those things.
是啊，如果你记得嘉莉·贝内特的采访，那是来自重温剧集，嘉莉分享说她和玛丽建立了关系，玛丽会帮助我们为节目获取当地的宝藏、道具、标志、披萨盒。顺便说一句，那是一次很棒的采访。如果你们还没听过，我们对嘉莉·贝内特的采访，她是《办公室》前四季的服装设计师。她在为节目带来的东西方面确实是开创性的。而与玛丽的关系就是其中之一。
But we put that business card in a nice prominent spot. That was our way of putting Mary on the show. Yay, Mary. So now we get to one of my favorite scenes. It's Michael sitting on Andy's desk while he's. He's trying to spy on Jim and David's meeting in the conference room. And he's just like throwing out random questions. Oh, lady, I have so much for this.
但我们把那张名片放在了一个显眼的好位置。那是我们把玛丽放进节目里的方式。耶，玛丽。所以现在我们到了我最喜欢的场景之一。那是迈克尔坐在安迪的办公桌上，当时他正在……他试图在会议室里窥探吉姆和戴维的会议。他只是在抛出一些随机的问题。哦，女士，我对此有很多话要说。
Are you ready? Yes. I love the scene. I know you loved it. In the episode, it starts with these two lines. Andy says, what can I do for you, Haas? Michael, staring into the conference room says, how are yourselves doing? But Jenna, the scene was so much bigger and big chunks of it were edited out for time.
你准备好了吗？是的。我喜欢这个场景。我知道你喜欢它。在这一集中，它以这两句台词开始。安迪说，我能为你做什么，哈斯（Haas）？迈克尔盯着会议室说，你们的销售情况如何？但是珍娜，这个场景本来大得多，其中很大一部分为了时间被剪掉了。
And I feel like we need to hear the full scene. I cannot believe there was more to one of my favorite scenes, and I cannot wait. So much more. All right. So Andy and Michael have this exchange, and then right after that, this would have happened. Are my sales done? They're good. Super solid.
我觉得我们需要听听完整的场景。我不敢相信我最喜欢的场景之一还有更多内容，我迫不及待了。多得多。好吧。所以安迪和迈克尔有这段对话，然后就在那之后，本来会发生这个。我的销售额完成了吗？它们很好。超级稳固。
What do you mean? Um, your retention. How that? How's your retention, Ben? Client retention? You're asking me about client retention? Well, I, um, Angela, my sales numbers are not updated, so that's on you. Stop haranguing me.
你是什么意思？嗯，你的留存率。那个怎么样？你的留存率怎么样，本？客户留存率？你在问我关于客户留存率的事？嗯，我，嗯，安吉拉，我的销售数据没有更新，所以那是你的责任。别再纠缠我了。
Stop haranguing me, all right? So Angela's like, stop haranguing me. And then here's the part that made it in. Andy's like, busted, my numbers are down a little bit. It's because of the economy. You're not buying it. You're good. Okay, the truth is, I've been having trouble focusing lately.
别再纠缠我了，好吗？所以安吉拉说，别再纠缠我了。然后这是进入正片的部分。安迪说，被抓住了，我的数据下降了一点。这是因为经济原因。你不相信。你很好。好吧，事实是，我最近一直难以集中注意力。
I'm in this weird, flirty, nepulous thing with this cousin of mine. It's a total mind effort, which leads to one of my favorite lines. Yes. Phyllis sang, again, with a cousin. It's so amazing the idea that Andy will not shut up about this weird cousin thing. But then he reads the email. Yes. He says, oh, I'm sorry, Phyllis, you explain this email, okay?
我和我的这个表亲之间有一种奇怪的、调情的、模糊不清的关系。这简直是一场脑力劳动，这引出了我最喜欢的台词之一。是的。菲利斯说，又来了，和表亲。安迪对这个奇怪的表亲事情喋喋不休，这太神奇了。但随后他读了那封邮件。是的。他说，哦，对不起，菲利斯，你解释一下这封邮件，好吗？
Hey, Andy, let's go visit Grandma and they get drunk together. Ha, ha. I mean, that's amazing. Okay. So what aired, it would have stopped there. But the scene keeps going. And this next part I call Angela coming in hot. Oh.
嘿，安迪，我们去拜访奶奶吧，然后他们一起喝醉了。哈，哈。我是说，那太棒了。好吧。所以播出的内容本来会在那里停止。但场景还在继续。而这下一部分我称之为“安吉拉火冒三丈”。哦。
I'll tell you the problem. The problem is that I'm backlogged because Michael hasn't signed off on any of the billing rates for the Buffalo clients. Shh, please. I'm trying to figure out what's going on in there, okay? They're probably talking about what a terrible job you're doing. You know what?
我会告诉你问题所在。问题是我的工作积压了，因为迈克尔还没有签署任何针对布法罗客户的账单费率。嘘，拜托。我正试图弄清楚里面发生了什么，好吗？他们可能在谈论你做得有多糟糕。你知道吗？
I bet they're worried about how you're managing this branch. I know I emailed David about it. Whoa! I know. And then this moment, leads to Michael and Andy hatching a plan. I need to find a way to get in there.
我敢打赌他们在担心你是如何管理这个分部的。我知道我为此给戴维发了邮件。哇！我知道。然后这一刻，导致了迈克尔和安迪制定了一个计划。我得想办法进去。
I need to fix his bridge. But first I need to get into that room. Check this out. I put together a cheese cart, hide you underneath, roll you in, all of a sudden, blammo, you can hear everything.
我得修好他的桥。但首先我得进那个房间。看看这个。我准备了一个奶酪车，把你藏在下面，把你推进去，突然之间，砰，你就能听到一切了。
I'm the branch manager. I'm not hiding underneath the cheese cart. As the branch manager, I used to garner respect. No, I got to think something else. Think something with dignity, okay? Caviar cart. Caviar cart.
我是分部经理。我不会藏在奶酪车下面。作为分部经理，我曾经赢得尊重。不，我得想点别的。想点有尊严的东西，好吗？鱼子酱车。鱼子酱车。
Something with dignity. I'll do the cart. I'll hide in a cart. Yeah, no problem. You can wheel me in, but make it classy. Please. Oh, wow. Now, I have to say I miss the stuff with Angela
想点有尊严的东西。我会推车。我会藏在车里。是啊，没问题。你可以把我推进去，但要弄得高级点。拜托。哦，哇。现在，我不得不说我怀念和安吉拉的那些内容，
because I think that that would get in Michael's head in such a way that it's his motivation for doing something so extreme as the cheese cart. Well, it heightens everything. It does. But at the same time, I like that they cut out the discussion of the cheese cart because that is such a funny reveal. Yes. After the commercial.
因为我认为那会以某种方式进入迈克尔的脑海，成为他做像奶酪车这样极端事情的动机。嗯，它提升了一切。确实。但与此同时，我喜欢他们剪掉了关于奶酪车的讨论，因为那是一个非常有趣的揭露。是的。在广告之后。
Yeah. Well, I think we should take a break. And then when we come back, it'll be all cheese cart. Oh, yeah. And we're going to learn something new about Andy in a deleted scene. We are back. And you know what? They say about a plan when it's just so crazy.
是啊。嗯，我觉得我们应该休息一下。然后当我们回来时，就全是奶酪车了。哦，是的。而且我们会在一个删除场景中了解关于安迪的新东西。我们回来了。你知道吗？他们关于一个计划是怎么说的，当它太疯狂时，
it might work? Yeah, Operation Cheese Cart. It's happening. You know why? It's just elegant. We have this talking head in the kitchen, and over Michael's shoulder, we can see Andy preparing a cheese cart. He's taking cheese out of some sandwiches. We had a fan catch from Gabby M in Phoenix, who said, when Andy is making the cheese plate, he takes five pieces of cheese off of someone's sandwich. Who puts five pieces of cheese on a sandwich? And I was like, good catch, Gabby. I have an answer for you. What? Remember those eight deleted scenes? Yes. Here's one of them. It would have happened later in the episode. Interior Kitchen, Kevin takes a bite out of his sandwich and looks confused. Kevin opens the sandwich and discovers the cheese is missing.
它可能会奏效？是啊，奶酪车行动。它正在发生。你知道为什么吗？它只是优雅。我们在厨房里有这个访谈，在迈克尔的肩膀上方，我们可以看到安迪在准备一个奶酪车。他正在从一些三明治里取出奶酪。我们收到了来自凤凰城加比·M的粉丝捕捉，她说，当安迪在制作奶酪盘时，他从某人的三明治上拿走了五片奶酪。谁会在三明治上放五片奶酪？我就想，好捕捉，加比。我有一个答案给你。什么？还记得那八个删除场景吗？是的。这是其中之一。它本来会发生在这一集的后面。室内厨房，凯文咬了一口他的三明治，看起来很困惑。凯文打开三明治，发现奶酪不见了。
Kevin says, hey, and sadly walks to the fridge, takes out the blue cheese dressing, and pours it onto his sandwich, and starts to eat it. It was Kevin's sandwich. He likes a lot of cheese. Gabby, Kevin likes five pieces of cheese. That's who. Now we realize that Michael is going to hide in the bottom of this cheese cart, Andy wheels him into the conference room and gives a. Big old speech about cheese. I mean, it's a fantastic speech.
凯文说，嘿，然后悲伤地走到冰箱前，拿出蓝纹奶酪酱，倒在他的三明治上，开始吃起来。那是凯文的三明治。他喜欢很多奶酪。加比，凯文喜欢五片奶酪。就是这样。现在我们意识到迈克尔要藏在这个奶酪车的底部，安迪把他推到会议室，并发表了一个……关于奶酪的宏大演讲。我是说，这是一个精彩的演讲。
We had a fan question from Christy R in Greensboro, North Carolina. And I'm just going to say, Christy R, you are reading my mind. What is it, Christy? Andy's cheese tray explanation is one of my favorite scenes. Was any part of this improvised? Were there any alts? Him talking about how the cheddar-style spread has reacted nicely with the air makes me laugh out loud every time.
我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州格林斯伯勒克里斯蒂·R的粉丝提问。我只想说，克里斯蒂·R，你读懂了我的心思。是什么，克里斯蒂？安迪的奶酪盘解释是我最喜欢的场景之一。这部分有即兴发挥吗？有什么替代台词吗？他谈论切达干酪风格的涂抹酱如何与空气发生良好反应让我每次都大笑出声。
Christy, me too. Same. Can we hear it? We have to. We have to hear it. I need to hear him say challenging and delicious. Yes, we, monsieur. From the Wisconsin region, a nice firm cheddar.
克里斯蒂，我也是。一样。我们能听听吗？我们必须听。我们必须听。我需要听他说“具有挑战性且美味”。是的，我们，先生。来自威斯康星地区，一种坚硬的切达干酪。
Also from the great state of Wisconsin, an aged parmesan. Here you will find a cheddar-style spread, which has reacted nicely with the air to form a light rind, which I think you'll find both challenging and delicious. At that point, I would recommend you take a quick trip south of the border to the great state of Illinois, where you will find this fine blue cheese dressing. If I may be so bold, it's a lot of fun to let the goldfish take a little swim in the blue cheese.
同样来自伟大的威斯康星州，一种陈年帕尔马干酪。在这里你会发现一种切达干酪风格的涂抹酱，它与空气发生了良好的反应，形成了一层轻薄的表皮，我想你会发现它既具有挑战性又美味。在那一点上，我建议你快速去一趟边境以南，去伟大的伊利诺伊州，在那里你会发现这种优质的蓝纹奶酪酱。如果我可以如此大胆地说，让金鱼在蓝纹奶酪里游个泳是很有趣的。
Bon Appetit. Okay. I checked the script and the line, which has reacted nicely with the air to form a light rind that I think you'll find both challenging and deletitie. delicious, was not in there. Also, the scripted version did not include the part about the goldfish going for a swim in the blue cheese. I do not know if Ed improvised these things, if they pitched them these lines on the fly, but I also think I can kind of almost hear Ed breaking at the
祝你胃口好。好吧。我查了剧本，那句“它与空气发生了良好的反应，形成了一层轻薄的表皮，我想你会发现它既具有挑战性又美味”并不在里面。此外，剧本版本也不包括关于金鱼去蓝纹奶酪里游泳的部分。我不知道埃德（Ed）是否即兴发挥了这些东西，如果他们当场给出了这些台词，但我还觉得我几乎能听到埃德在
beginning of this cheese speech because I just know his voice so well. Yeah. And I have to imagine there are bloopers. I have to imagine. I have not seen them. They are not on the blooper reel. but I don't know. You know there were bloopers. Come on. Him and John in the same room together and him saying all that stuff. Forget it. Also, we had a fan catch from Sessia Z in London, Ontario, Canada.
这个奶酪演讲开始时笑场了，因为我太熟悉他的声音了。是啊。而且我不得不想象有NG镜头。我不得不想象。我没见过它们。它们不在NG镜头集锦里。但我不知道。你知道有NG镜头。拜托。他和约翰在同一个房间里，而他说所有那些东西。算了吧。此外，我们收到了来自加拿大安大略省伦敦市塞西亚·Z的粉丝捕捉。
If you look closely at 8 minutes, 55 seconds, you can see Michael peeking out of the sheet from the cheese platter cart. And you can. It is amazing. It says Andy is leaving. Michael just like peeks out the corner. Because I had thought to myself, did they make Steve really sit in that cheese cart for all of that? I think he was in there. I think he was.
如果你仔细看8分55秒，你可以看到迈克尔从奶酪盘车的布里探出头来。确实可以看到。这太神奇了。上面写着安迪要离开了。迈克尔就像从角落里探出头来。因为我曾对自己想，他们真的让史蒂夫坐在那个奶酪车里拍了所有那些吗？我想他在里面。我想他是。
Because what if he did something? And they wanted it on camera. You never know, with Steve, right? Well, you know what it reminded me of? It reminded me of the time that I was on Busy Phillips talk show. And it was my birthday. And Busy was giving me all these presents one by one from cast members of the office. What did I give you?
因为如果他做了什么呢？而他们想把它拍下来。你永远不知道，对于史蒂夫，对吧？嗯，你知道它让我想起了什么吗？它让我想起了我上比西·菲利普斯（Busy Phillips）脱口秀的那次。那是我的生日。比西正一个接一个地给我所有来自《办公室》演员的礼物。我给了你什么？
You gave me a T-shirt with a picture of bread on it. Mm-hmm. I believe Ellie sent me a jar of rosemary crackers. Yes, she did. We'll tell you all about that in the finale episode. You're going to have to wait for it. But there was this giant box on the stage. And that was the final gift.
你给了我一件印有面包图案的T恤。嗯哼。我相信艾莉（Ellie）寄给我一罐迷迭香饼干。是的，她寄了。我们会在大结局那一集告诉你所有关于那个的事。你得等着看。但舞台上有一个巨大的盒子。那是最后的礼物。
What was it? What was this box going to be? Can I point out it was on the stage for like 20 minutes? A long time. Yeah. A very long time. And I was like going on and on about sourdough starter. All the while this big box is sitting.
那是什么？这个盒子会是什么？我可以指出它在舞台上放了大约20分钟吗？很长一段时间。是啊。非常长的时间。而我一直在喋喋不休地谈论酸面团发酵剂。与此同时，这个大盒子一直放在那里。
there. And after 20, 30 minutes of this taping, Steve Correll popped out of the box. Yeah, Busy was like, Busy was like, there's one more gift. I know. And poor Steve had been sitting in a box for half an hour. But who knows how long he'd been there because he probably had to crawl in it before you came out on stage. Well, Busy did this whole crazy thing during the break where she was like, Jenna, come here. I want to take a picture with you inside of our photo booth. And I was like, okay, and then we went in there and she was like, oh, it's not working. It's not working. You stay in here. Stay in the photo booth while I, we're going to fix. She was like, guys, you've got to fix the booth. And she would not let me out of this photo booth. It was so, I remember thinking like, this is odd.
那里。而在这次录制的20、30分钟后，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔从盒子里跳了出来。是啊，比西就像，比西就像，还有一个礼物。我知道。而可怜的史蒂夫已经在盒子里坐了半个小时了。但谁知道他在那里待了多久，因为他可能在你上台之前就得爬进去。嗯，比西在休息期间做了整个疯狂的事情，当时她就像，珍娜，过来。我想和你一起在我们的照相亭里拍张照片。我就说，好吧，然后我们进去了，她就像，哦，它坏了。它坏了。你待在这里。待在照相亭里，等我，我们要修好它。她就像，伙计们，你们得修好这个亭子。她不让我离开这个照相亭。这太……我记得当时想，这很奇怪。
She really wants the photo booth picture. I mean, this is very Angela Kinsey of her. But I think that was when Steve was loading into the box. Well, yeah, they were trying to keep you tucked away so you wouldn't see. But I was so surprised. And then I think the first thing I said was How long have you been in there? But anyway, when he was hiding in the cheese cart, I was like, oh my God, that reminds me of when he hit in that box. I must have watched that scene, Jenna, probably five times. I just loved it so much. Same.
她真的很想要那张照相亭的照片。我是说，这非常安吉拉·金赛。但我认为那是史蒂夫正在装进盒子里的时候。嗯，是啊，他们试图把你藏起来，这样你就不会看到。但我太惊讶了。然后我想我说的第一句话是，你在里面待了多久？但总之，当他躲在奶酪车里时，我就想，哦，天哪，那让我想起了他躲在那个盒子里的时候。我一定看了那个场景五遍，珍娜，我太喜欢它了。一样。
And I had this moment where I was like, has Ed been a waiter? Because that was so good. Yeah. Has he served cheese? Has he served cheese or some kind of food? But we did find some really great new information about Andy in a deleted scene. Jenna, it would have come earlier in the kitchen. But this is why Andy knows so much about cheese.
而且我当时想，埃德当过服务员吗？因为那太棒了。是啊。他端过奶酪吗？他端过奶酪或某种食物吗？但我们确实在删除场景中发现了一些关于安迪的非常棒的新信息。珍娜，它本来会更早出现在厨房里。但这就是为什么安迪对奶酪了解这么多的原因。
You got to hear it. No, no, no. No. What? You don't put a soft cheese next to a hard cheese. I was making a smiley face. Mm-hmm. Okay.
你得听听。不，不，不。不。什么？你不能把软奶酪放在硬奶酪旁边。我正在做一个笑脸。嗯哼。好吧。
Let me ask you something. Did you also spend a summer in Toulouse apprenticing for a farmajorie? Hmm? What? Yeah, I didn't think so. All right. You know a lot about cheeses. I just, I've already started.
让我问你一件事。你也在图卢兹度过了一个夏天，在一家奶酪店当学徒吗？嗯？什么？是啊，我就知道不是。好吧。你对奶酪了解很多。我只是，我已经开始了。
I'll just, all right. Oh, hey, what do you think I should say if I get caught? First of all, it's a foolproof plan. I know. But something were to happen. What should I say? CART, cart. I got it.
我只是，好吧。哦，嘿，你觉得如果我被抓住了该说什么？首先，这是一个万无一失的计划。我知道。但如果发生了什么事。我该说什么？车，车。我知道了。
Poulge and me. Do you have any great poop? Yes. I will use the great poop line. Now I sort of want to get caught. Oh my gosh. Okay, first of all, Andy was a Frommagier apprentice. Yes.
灰扑蓬（Grey Poupon）。你有任何灰扑蓬吗？是的。我会用那句灰扑蓬的台词。现在我有点想被抓住了。哦，天哪。好吧，首先，安迪是一个奶酪学徒。是的。
Yeah. Second of all, the gray Poupon. Don't you wish that it happened? I kind of needed to happen. I totally remember those commercials. I did too, which sent me down a rabbit hole last night. You remember guys, they were a long time ago, but there would be sort of a very elegant, refined gentleman in a Rolls-Royce, eating an elaborate sandwich with gray Poupon in the back seat. Yeah, like on a little mini tray. Yes. As if he was on an airplane and like an English countryside. side, and another Rolls-Royce with another older distinguished gentleman would pull up and they would say this. Pardon me. Would you have any gray-pupon? But of course.
是啊。其次，灰扑蓬。你不希望它发生吗？我有点需要它发生。我完全记得那些广告。我也记得，这让我昨晚陷入了一个兔子洞。你们记得吗，伙计们，那是很久以前的事了，但会有一个非常优雅、精致的绅士坐在劳斯莱斯里，在后座吃着精致的三明治，配着灰扑蓬。是啊，就像在一个小托盘上。是的。就好像他在飞机上，在英国乡村一样。另一辆劳斯莱斯载着另一位年长的杰出绅士会开过来，他们会这样说。打扰一下。你有灰扑蓬吗？当然。
So, of course, that wasn't where I stopped, Jenna, with my gray-pupon research. Of course not. I would hope not. I had to go to the Grey Pupon website, and there's a lot of fascinating things about gray Pupon. Did you know it was made with wine? No. Yes. And not only that, did you know that Grey Pupon made a wine? Wait, what? Yes. They're a winemaker and a fancy mustard maker? They make fancy mustard, but they decided to feature a white wine. It was called La Moutard Vinn, probably saying it wrong. And it was inspired by their Grey Poupon mustard. Here is how the wine is described, Jenna. Are you ready? Yes.
所以，当然，那不是我停止的地方，珍娜，关于我的灰扑蓬研究。当然不是。我希望不是。我不得不去灰扑蓬网站，关于灰扑蓬有很多迷人的事情。你知道它是用葡萄酒做的吗？不。是的。不仅如此，你知道灰扑蓬做过一种葡萄酒吗？等等，什么？是的。他们是一个酿酒师和一个高级芥末制造商？他们做高级芥末，但他们决定推出一种白葡萄酒。它叫La Moutard Vinn，我可能说错了。它的灵感来自他们的灰扑蓬芥末。这是这种酒的描述方式，珍娜。你准备好了吗？是的。
bright hints of spice, pronounced citrus, floral characteristics balanced by vibrant acidity, with the typical texture and roundness on the palate you'd expect from a vognier. Probably saying that wrong. So guess what? What? I thought we both needed a bottle. What? What?
明亮的香料气息，明显的柑橘、花香特征，被充满活力的酸度所平衡，带有你从维欧尼（vognier）中期待的典型质地和圆润感。可能说错了。所以猜猜怎么着？什么？我想我们俩都需要一瓶。什么？什么？
And I tried to buy the gray coupon white wine. What? It's sold out! Oh my God! I am going to tell you right now that I have never in my life. craved more, a sandwich with gray Poupon mustard and a glass of their mustard wine. What? I need it now.
我试着买灰扑蓬白葡萄酒。什么？卖光了！哦，天哪！我现在要告诉你，我这辈子从来没有。更渴望一个配灰扑蓬芥末的三明治和一杯他们的芥末酒。什么？我现在就需要它。
Well, I'm going to keep trying to buy it. You had me so excited and now I am so sad. I'm going to keep trying to buy it because even as I read the description of the white wine inspired by gray Poupon mustard. Yes. It sounded like Andy describing the cheese cart. I mean, with a typical texture and roundness on the palate. Wow. And that wraps up the cheese cart, deleted scene runner.
嗯，我会继续尝试买它的。你让我太兴奋了，现在我太难过了。我会继续尝试买它的，因为即使当我读到灵感来自灰扑蓬芥末的白葡萄酒的描述时。是的。它听起来就像安迪在描述奶酪车。我是说，带有典型的质地和圆润的口感。哇。而这就结束了奶酪车删除场景的连贯性。
I'd like to share with everyone for you, Angela, that you love cheese. I love cheese. When we went out to dinner in New York, where we were celebrating our billboard in Times Square. 200 million downloads. So amazing. We went to dinner. And on the menu, one of the options is a cheese plate with fancy cheeses. Yes, several different kinds you can pick.
我想和大家分享一下，安吉拉，你喜欢奶酪。我喜欢奶酪。当我们在纽约出去吃晚餐时，我们在那里庆祝我们在时代广场的广告牌。2亿次下载。太棒了。我们去吃晚餐。在菜单上，其中一个选择是配高级奶酪的奶酪盘。是的，你可以挑选几种不同的。
And this is Angela reading the menu. I'm going to be Angela reading the menu. Well, I definitely want cheese. I don't know what else I want, but I'm going to need to get cheese. What do you want to start? Do you want some cheeses? I want some cheeses. I don't know.
这是安吉拉在读菜单。我要成为读菜单的安吉拉。嗯，我绝对想要奶酪。我不知道我还想要什么，但我需要点奶酪。你想从什么开始？你想来点奶酪吗？我想要一些奶酪。我不知道。
Then you were like, should we have cheeses after? I said, how about cheese as like a dessert course? Because we were hungry and we wanted a bunch of food. Yeah. And I said, why don't we see how we feel at the end? And maybe we get cheese as dessert and wine. That's the way they do it in Europe, right? You end with cheese.
然后你就说，我们之后要不要来点奶酪？我说，把奶酪当作甜点怎么样？因为我们饿了，我们想吃很多食物。是啊。我说，为什么我们不看看最后感觉如何呢？也许我们把奶酪当作甜点和葡萄酒。这就是他们在欧洲的做法，对吧？你以奶酪结束。
Right. Well, we ate, and the restaurant was so kind to us. They brought us an extra appetizer on the house. They were office ladies fans. Yeah. And then we had big hearty pasta. We were too full for cheese. And I watched Angela get real sad when she realized that she would not be ordering cheese.
对。嗯，我们吃了，餐厅对我们太好了。他们免费送了我们一份额外的开胃菜。他们是《办公室》女士的粉丝。是啊。然后我们吃了丰盛的意大利面。我们太饱了，吃不下奶酪。我看着安吉拉意识到她不会点奶酪时变得真的很伤心。
This woman loves cheese. I love cheese. I love all kinds of cheese. I once bought a super stinky cheese that my family asked me to put in the garage. because it had stunk up our fridge so bad. And when I would take it out to eat it, literally the kids were like, ugh. All right, guys, we got a little off topic. Who, us?
这个女人喜欢奶酪。我喜欢奶酪。我喜欢各种各样的奶酪。我曾经买过一种超级臭的奶酪，我的家人让我把它放在车库里。因为它把我们的冰箱熏得太厉害了。当我把它拿出来吃的时候，孩子们真的说，呃。好吧，伙计们，我们有点跑题了。谁，我们？
No. But forgive us. It was cheese. If anything's going to take us off topic, it's going to be cheese. Cheese. And then when you find out a fancy mustard made of wine, come on. I mean, it was inevitable. At the end of the scene, though, David Wallace is going to leave the conference room.
不。但请原谅我们。那是奶酪。如果有什么东西会让我们跑题，那一定是奶酪。奶酪。然后当你发现一种用葡萄酒做的花式芥末时，拜托。我是说，这是不可避免的。不过，在场景结束时，戴维·华莱士要离开会议室了。
and Michael is going to wheel himself out of the office. With one foot, Steve really did that. It's amazing. And then Wallace is going to say, we have a chat in your office. That's going to pay off in a little bit. But first, Toby and Dwight are on a stakeout at Daryl's house. Yeah, and I have a question for my train aficionados out there. Yeah.
而迈克尔要推着自己离开办公室。用一只脚，史蒂夫真的做到了。这太神奇了。然后华莱士要说，我们在你的办公室聊聊。那会在一会儿后得到回报。但首先，托比和德怀特在达里尔家进行监视。是啊，我有一个问题要问我的火车爱好者们。是啊。
Does this train lingo track, see what I do. did there? Does the train link? Hey! That is, that's like dad level pun right there. I know. Dad pun. Dad pun. Yeah. Because I'll tell you why. Toby says sounds like an EMD P40. Dwight says, no, that's a GE. A P40 is much higher pitched. So I looked all that up. I couldn't find anything called an EMD P40. I did find a six-axil passenger diesel electric locomotive built by General Motors Electromotive Division called an EMD-S-D-P-40. Okay. But we saw a picture of the train, and it was not a passenger train.
这个火车行话对吗，看看我做了什么。那个双关语。火车链接吗？嘿！那简直是爸爸级别的双关语。我知道。爸爸双关语。爸爸双关语。是啊。因为我会告诉你为什么。托比说听起来像EMD P40。德怀特说，不，那是GE。P40的音调高得多。所以我查了所有这些。我找不到任何叫EMD P40的东西。我确实找到了一个由通用汽车电气动力部门制造的六轴客运柴油电力机车，叫EMD-S-D-P-40。好吧。但我们看到了火车的照片，它不是客运列车。
That's right. And GE does make locomotives for freight trains. They're a leading manufacturer. So maybe Dwight was right. I don't know, guys. My train people, is this accurate? I just love that Dwight is able to differentiate trains by the sound of the train horn. By the pitch?
没错。而且GE确实为货运列车制造机车。他们是领先的制造商。所以也许德怀特是对的。我不知道，伙计们。我的火车迷们，这准确吗？我只是喜欢德怀特能够通过火车喇叭的声音来区分火车。通过音调？
Yeah, that's kind of amazing. Train people, let us know. Is this accurate? Well, here's what's going to happen on their stakeout. Oh, my gosh, they see Daryl, not on crutches, walking with a giant bag of dog food on his shoulder. Right. Same jersey walking from behind, can't see his face. They're positive. It's him.
是啊，那有点神奇。火车迷们，让我们知道。这准确吗？嗯，这就是他们监视时会发生的事。哦，天哪，他们看到达里尔，没有拄拐杖，肩上扛着一大袋狗粮走着。对。同样的球衣从后面走过来，看不见他的脸。他们肯定那是他。
Guess what? That's not him. It's his sister. It is. But they've already shouted and revealed themselves to be, like, on the stakeout and Then they peel away and they run into some trash cans. Oh, no, they make total asses of themselves. Yes.
猜猜怎么着？那不是他。那是他的妹妹。确实是。但他们已经大喊大叫并暴露了自己，就像在监视一样，然后他们跑开了，撞到了一些垃圾桶。哦，不，他们让自己彻底出丑了。是的。
And they're completely busted. Well, location alert. We shot this scene on Emolita Street in Van Nuys, California. Phil Shea created that enormous dog food bag using a fictional label created by our graphics designer, Ryan Cosgrove. And it was our stunt coordinator, Sean Crowder, who was doubled for Dwight driving into the trash cans. They also had a stunt double for Toby. in that scene, and I looked at it, it's amazing. Could you tell?
而且他们彻底被抓住了。嗯，地点警报。我们在加利福尼亚州范奈斯的埃莫利塔街拍摄了这个场景。菲尔·谢（Phil Shea）使用我们的图形设计师瑞安·科斯格罗夫（Ryan Cosgrove）创作的虚构标签制作了那个巨大的狗粮袋。而且是我们的特技协调员肖恩·克劳德（Sean Crowder），他替身德怀特开车撞进垃圾桶。他们在那一幕中也有托比的特技替身，我看了，太神奇了。你看出来了吗？
No. I didn't catch it. I could not tell, but the stunt person who was playing Toby does this, like, really hardcore, like, jerk forward. And so later, when Toby is, like, icing his forehead, like, clearly that was, like, planned. That was tracked. But it's good. It was a good stunt.
没有。我没发现。我看不出来，但扮演托比的特技演员做了这个，就像，非常硬核的，就像，向前猛冲。所以后来，当托比就像，冰敷他的额头时，显然那是，就像，计划好的。那是追踪到的。但它很好。这是一个很好的特技。
I think we should title this next scene, too cool for. school in the break room. Yeah. Oh, boy. Ryan. Pam is trying to find out if Ryan is coming to the wedding. He's like, yeah, I might stop by. And Pam's like, I might stop by. This is a wedding, Ryan. I know. There's no might stop by. Pam is like, it's $75 a plate, so I kind of need a solid answer. And Ryan's like, oh, I once drank a 77 glass of cognac. And, you know, yeah, I'll come to the wedding. Probably. I'll probably come. I have a fun fact. Okay. The most expensive bottle of cognac in the world is a bottle of Gautier, cognac, from 1962. It sold at auction for $144,525 in May of 2020. Whose cognac was it? Was it like Da Vinci's cognac? Who had that cognac? Why is it so special? I don't know. But because there are only three bottles.
我觉得我们应该给下一个场景起个标题，休息室里太酷了。是啊。哦，男孩。瑞安。帕姆正试图找出瑞安是否会来参加婚礼。他说，是啊，我可能会顺便过来。帕姆说，我可能会顺便过来。这是一场婚礼，瑞安。我知道。没有“可能会顺便过来”。帕姆说，每盘75美元，所以我需要一个确定的答案。瑞安说，哦，我曾经喝过一杯77美元的干邑白兰地。而且，你知道，是啊，我会去参加婚礼。可能吧。我可能会去。我有一个有趣的事实。好吧。世界上最昂贵的干邑白兰地是一瓶1962年的Gautier干邑。它在2020年5月的拍卖会上以144,525美元的价格售出。那是谁的干邑？那是达芬奇的干邑吗？谁有那种干邑？为什么它这么特别？我不知道。但因为只有三瓶。
of this, quote, exceedingly rare spirit that still exists today, and all of them still have their original labels. So people, check your liquor cabinets, because if you have one of the other two bottles, you are swimming in $144,525. If your grandfather has an old bottle of cognac wedged in the back that his grandfather gave him, it might be your lottery ticket. Yeah. Well, David and Michael are going to have a scene now where David is basically like, Michael, can you handle all these new responsibilities? And also, what do you think about Jim in a leadership role? Yeah. And Michael thinks that, you know, Jim would be kind of replacing him or maybe leaving the branch. And so he, like, talks bad about Jim. He calls him the big bird of the office. He shows David Toby's report on Jim, which you know is going to be
这种，引用，极其罕见的烈酒今天仍然存在，而且它们都保留了原始标签。所以伙计们，检查你们的酒柜，因为如果你有另外两瓶中的一瓶，你就沉浸在144,525美元里了。如果你爷爷在后面塞了一瓶旧干邑，是他爷爷给他的，那可能是你的彩票。是啊。嗯，戴维和迈克尔现在要有一个场景，戴维基本上是说，迈克尔，你能处理所有这些新职责吗？还有，你觉得吉姆担任领导角色怎么样？是啊。迈克尔认为，你知道，吉姆会取代他或者可能离开分部。所以他，就像，说吉姆的坏话。他称他为办公室的大鸟。他给戴维看了托比关于吉姆的报告，你知道那会是
so petty because Toby's in love with Pam. Yeah. And this is. clearly an old report because it says Jim spends a lot of time at reception, which we know Pam is no longer at. Well, there was a Jim talking head in the shooting draft that didn't make it in. Yet another one of those deleted scenes, right? This is what Jim would have said. So it turns out Pam's dowry was a bit disappointing. It was mostly just stuffed animals and scrunchies. And a kid can't live on scrunchies. The stuffed animals may come in handy. Anyway, yeah, I need a promotion. Pam's dowry list of animals and scrunchies. You know, what's funny to be about that is that it was Jim who brought the debt into their marriage with the purchase of his parents' home. I knew. I knew I was going to stir the pot. I'm just saying. I'm just saying. I knew when I read it, I would stir the Jim and Pam pot.
如此琐碎，因为托比爱上了帕姆。是啊。而且这显然是一份旧报告，因为它说吉姆花了很多时间在前台，我们知道帕姆已经不在那里了。嗯，在拍摄草稿中有一个吉姆的访谈，但没放进去。又是那些删除场景之一，对吧？这就是吉姆本来会说的。所以事实证明帕姆的嫁妆有点令人失望。它大多只是毛绒玩具和发圈。而孩子不能靠发圈生活。毛绒玩具可能派得上用场。总之，是啊，我需要升职。帕姆的动物和发圈嫁妆清单。你知道，对我来说有趣的是，是吉姆在购买他父母的房子时把债务带进了他们的婚姻。我知道。我知道我会搅浑水。我只是说。我只是说。我知道当我读到它时，我会搅动吉姆和帕姆的锅。
Well, it was in this scene with David Wallace that I saw all the sticky notes on the computer. And also there's a fan catch from Kane H from California. who said, in the meeting, Michael says he has to talk to his guy from H&R Block. But in job fair, Michael says, what does H&R Block do? So has Michael learned what H&R Block does? Or does he just say it to try to be relatable? Well, I like that catch, Kane, and I'm pretty sure that he is using it wrong, because he tells David Wallace he has to talk to his mother and his H&R Block guy about being
嗯，就是在和戴维·华莱士的这一幕中，我看到了电脑上的所有便利贴。而且还有一个来自加利福尼亚州凯恩·H的粉丝捕捉。他说，在会议中，迈克尔说他必须和他在H&R Block的人谈谈。但在招聘会上，迈克尔说，H&R Block是做什么的？所以迈克尔了解H&R Block是做什么的了吗？还是他只是为了显得有共鸣才这么说的？嗯，我喜欢那个捕捉，凯恩，我很确定他用错了，因为他告诉戴维·华莱士他必须和他的母亲以及他的H&R Block的人谈谈关于被
promoted to all Northeast sales. I'm not sure why you need your guide H&R Block to weigh in. I think he should weigh in on everything. I think that's what Michael thinks. Relationship advice. Well, Jim does have a talking head, Angela, where he says that the reason he didn't tell Michael about all of this promotion stuff was that he was afraid Michael would try to help and that it would be a debacle. And he notes that Michael once handed out jello shots at the 23rd mile of the Steentown Marathon. We got some mail from Greg Z in Pocono Pines, Pennsylvania.
提升到整个东北地区的销售。我不确定为什么你需要你的H&R Block向导来权衡。我认为他应该对一切进行权衡。我认为迈克尔就是这么想的。关系建议。嗯，吉姆确实有一个访谈，安吉拉，他说他没有告诉迈克尔所有这些升职的事情的原因是他害怕迈克尔会试图帮忙，那会是一场灾难。他指出迈克尔曾经在斯坦敦马拉松（Steentown Marathon）的第23英里处分发果冻酒。我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州波科诺派恩斯格雷格·Z的邮件。
What's up, Greg? I found this a delightful letter. Greg Z says, As you two plan your epic road trip to Scranton, Pennsylvania, I propose that you add the Steamedown Marathon to your list of must-doos. In fact, how fun would it be for you two to make an appearance at the 23rd mile of the race, the exact spot where Michael handed out his jello shots? P.S., I am currently training for my 3rd.
怎么了，格雷格？我发现这是一封令人愉快的信。格雷格·Z说，当你们俩计划你们去宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的史诗公路旅行时，我建议你们把斯坦敦马拉松加入你们的必做清单。事实上，你们俩在比赛的第23英里处露面会有多有趣，正是迈克尔分发果冻酒的地方？附言，我目前正在为我的第三次。
13th, Steam Town Marathon myself, and I listen to your podcast every Wednesday, or sometimes I save it for my long runs on Sundays. A lot of people are surprised that I listen to podcast instead of music while running, but I think a podcast about a show set in Scranton is the perfect listening choice while preparing for a race that ends in Scranton. Oh, Greg, I love that. Greg, I hope you're running right now. Hello. Hello. How's it going? I hope you're hydrated. have really comfortable running shoes. Keep going. Keep going. You can do it. Pep Talks by Jen and Angela. Yeah.
第13届斯坦敦马拉松训练，我每周三听你们的播客，或者有时我把它留到周日的长跑时听。很多人很惊讶我在跑步时听播客而不是音乐，但我认为关于一部以斯克兰顿为背景的节目的播客是在准备一场以斯克兰顿为终点的比赛时的完美选择。哦，格雷格，我喜欢那个。格雷格，我希望你现在正在跑步。你好。你好。怎么样？我希望你补充了水分。有非常舒适的跑鞋。继续。继续。你能做到的。珍和安吉拉的励志谈话。是啊。
David's going to ask Jim to walk him to his car. I think this is never a good thing, guys. I think of someone says, hey, can you walk me to my car? They're going to tell you something. Yeah. Some Shataki's going to go down. Yeah. And when Jim comes back in the office, he's clearly bummed by whatever it is David said to him. Yeah, Michael tries to bring him some jelly beans. And I want you to know he's done. He's done. Definitely bummed because at 13 minutes, 50 seconds, he's taken off his jacket. Oh. His ambition jacket, as I like to call it.
戴维要让吉姆陪他走到车前。我认为这从来都不是好事，伙计们。我想如果有人说，嘿，你能陪我走到车前吗？他们要告诉你一些事情。是啊。有些事要发生了。是啊。当吉姆回到办公室时，他显然对戴维对他说的任何话感到沮丧。是啊，迈克尔试图给他带一些软糖豆。而且我想让你知道他完了。他完了。绝对沮丧，因为在13分50秒，他脱掉了他的夹克。哦。他的雄心夹克，正如我喜欢称呼它的那样。
I think his ambition has been deflated. Aw. Yeah. Ambition jacket. Yeah. So they're going to go into Michael's office. Jim is like, I need to find out what you told David Wallace. I'd also like to point out that as they walk into Michael's office, I still have my binder on my
我认为他的雄心已经被泄气了。啊。是啊。雄心夹克。是啊。所以他们要进入迈克尔的办公室。吉姆说，我需要找出你告诉戴维·华莱士什么了。我还想指出，当他们走进迈克尔的办公室时，我的活页夹还在我的
desk that I've been working on. I've been working on that binder all day. And you know what, guys? She really did. By the end of this episode, Pam would have had a stellar binder thanks to Jenna. Yeah, I don't know what the binder is about, but it's going to be great. Toby's not looking so good. Dwight is checking his pupils to see if they're dilated. He's got a big red mark on his forehead. Yep. And Darrell buss in. And it's like, hey, you called my sister an a hole. You drove into my trash cans. He's ticked off. Yeah. Darrell went. to call corporate and file a complaint. Guys, guest star alert, Daryl's sister Gwyneth was played by Jamila Jackson.
我一直在处理的办公桌。我整天都在处理那个活页夹。你们知道吗，伙计们？她真的做到了。到这一集结束时，多亏了珍娜，帕姆会拥有一个很棒的活页夹。是的，我不知道那个活页夹是关于什么的，但它会很棒。托比看起来不太好。德怀特正在检查他的瞳孔，看它们是否放大。他的额头上有一个大红印。是的。然后达里尔冲了进来。就像是，嘿，你骂我妹妹是混蛋。你开车撞进了我的垃圾桶。他气坏了。是的。达里尔去向公司投诉了。伙计们，客串明星警报，达里尔的妹妹格温妮丝由贾米拉·杰克逊饰演。
She is so good. She is so good in this scene. Perfect. She's going to appear in another episode as well, and Randy Cordray told us that after they cast her, she agreed to let Debbie Pierce cut her hair to match Craig for this role. Well, it really sold it. I mean, that's commitment. That's actor commitment.
她太棒了。她在这一幕里表现得太好了。完美。她也会出现在另一集中，兰迪·科德雷告诉我们，在选定她之后，她同意让黛比·皮尔斯剪掉她的头发，以配合克雷格在这个角色中的形象。嗯，这真的很令人信服。我是说，那是奉献精神。那是演员的奉献精神。
It is. And sometimes you get asked to do that stuff. Yeah, I remember they would put that in the breakdowns for roles if there was like something you needed to do. Like, I don't know, shave your head or grow a beard or dye your hair, dark dark brown like I did for haters back off. Yes. I was a full brunette for two years. Yep. Freaked my family out.
确实。有时你会受邀做那种事。是的，我记得如果角色需要做些什么，他们会把这些写在角色要求里。比如，我不知道，剃光头、留胡子或者把头发染成深棕色，就像我为《恨者退后》做的那样。是的。我整整两年都是全黑发。是的。把我家人吓坏了。
Well, Jamila, thanks for doing that because we loved you as Daryl's sister. Dwight and Toby are going to have to go down to the warehouse. they're going to apologize. But then Dwight notices that some of the other warehouse workers are using the lift to get down from the top of the stairs. Instead of the stairs.
好吧，贾米拉，谢谢你这样做，因为我们很喜欢你饰演的达里尔的妹妹。德怀特和托比将不得不去仓库。他们要去道歉。但随后德怀特注意到其他一些仓库工人正在使用升降机从楼梯顶部下来。而不是走楼梯。
They're like crawling through the banister on top of the lift and then going zh, and going down. And Dwight's like, hold on, I think you hurt your leg using the lift instead of the stairs. And here's my evidence. There's this new piece of wood up there.
他们就像爬过升降机顶部的栏杆，然后发出“嗖”的一声，滑了下去。德怀特说，等等，我想你用升降机而不是走楼梯把腿弄伤了。这是我的证据。上面有一块新木板。
Right. Shenanigans. busted. Dwight is right. Daryl's like, uh, yeah. So Dwight is like, I'm going to file a complaint because Daryl lied. Daryl is like, I'm going to file a complaint because you harassed my sister. Toby is like, no paperwork, we're all just going to move on. There's an epic stare down between Daryl, his sister, and Dwight. And it ends with Toby at his desk being like, so. Dwight and Daryl decided to file complaints on one another. So now Toby is in a mountain of paperwork.
没错。恶作剧。被抓住了。德怀特是对的。达里尔说，呃，是的。所以德怀特说，我要投诉，因为达里尔撒谎了。达里尔说，我要投诉，因为你骚扰了我妹妹。托比说，别搞文书工作了，我们大家都继续前进吧。达里尔、他妹妹和德怀特之间进行了一场史诗般的对视。最后托比坐在办公桌前说，好吧。德怀特和达里尔决定互相投诉。所以现在托比陷入了堆积如山的文书工作中。
With his red shalight forehead from running into trash cans. And his little stuffed doggy. Toby. All right. Well, we have one more storyline to wrap up here. Michael is going to call David Wallace in front of Jim and try to both save his own ass and tell David Wallace that he thinks that Jim is a good person for this promotion. Jim makes him put David on speakerphone. And he lies at first and says Jim is not there.
还有他因为撞进垃圾桶而留下的红色额头。以及他那只毛绒小狗。托比。好吧。我们这里还有一个故事情节要收尾。迈克尔要在吉姆面前给大卫·华莱士打电话，试图既保住自己的饭碗，又告诉大卫·华莱士他认为吉姆是这次晋升的合适人选。吉姆让他把大卫设为免提。他起初撒谎说吉姆不在。
And then David is like, I want Jim to be there. So he does like this funny little like, oh. He's walking in. Here he is. Oh, hey. Sitting down. Well, I had to look it up in the script. I wanted to know, did Steve improvise that in the moment?
然后大卫说，我希望吉姆在那里。所以他做了个滑稽的小动作，哦。他正走进来。他在这儿。哦，嘿。坐下。好吧，我得去剧本里查一下。我想知道，那是史蒂夫当时即兴发挥的吗？
That was in the script. It was so funny. Steve did it so well. But also in the scene, Angela, David says, hey, I talked to Alan and we had this idea that you guys would become like co-managers. Michael, you're going to handle like the sort of big picture stuff. Jim, you handle the day to day. What do you think?
那是剧本里的。太搞笑了。史蒂夫演得真好。但在那一幕里，安吉拉，大卫说，嘿，我和艾伦谈过了，我们有个主意，你们可以成为联席经理。迈克尔，你负责处理大局方面的事情。吉姆，你处理日常事务。你们觉得怎么样？
And Michael's like, I don't know. And David's like, listen, this is the only way I could sell it to Alan. Who's Alan? Who is Alan? Who is this guy? Who the hell is Alan? I don't know who Alan is. But Alan's in charge.
迈克尔说，我不知道。大卫说，听着，这是我能说服艾伦的唯一方法。艾伦是谁？艾伦是谁？这家伙是谁？艾伦到底是谁？我不知道艾伦是谁。但艾伦负责。
Clearly. We never meet Alan. I've never heard of Alan before. Well, Alan, whoever you are, this isn't going to go well. It's not going to go well, Ellen. It's a terrible idea. Terrible idea. We'll see how it goes next week at least.
显然。我们从未见过艾伦。我以前从未听说过艾伦。好吧，艾伦，不管你是谁，这都不会有好结果。这不会有好结果的，艾伦。这是个糟糕的主意。糟糕的主意。至少我们下周看看情况如何。
It is not going to go well, Alan. Sorry to say. Well, I love this next moment. Dwight is going to burst in to make an announcement, right? Mm-hmm. What he's discovered in the warehouse. But Michael was already making an announcement that he and Jim will now co-manage the Scranton branch. Dwight,
这不会有好结果的，艾伦。很遗憾。好吧，我喜欢接下来的这一刻。德怀特要冲进来宣布一件事，对吧？嗯哼。他在仓库里发现了什么。但迈克尔已经在宣布他和吉姆现在将共同管理斯克兰顿分公司。德怀特，
Dwight looks like someone hit him in the face with a frying pan. He's like, what the F? And then he has a talking head that's just a scream. Like a primal scream. We had a fan question from Winter P. From Fort Wayne, Indiana, my birthplace. That's where I was born. How about that?
德怀特看起来就像被人用平底锅打在脸上一样。他就像，什么鬼？然后他有一个谈话头镜头，只是尖叫。就像原始的尖叫。我们有一个来自印第安纳州韦恩堡的温特·P的粉丝提问，那是我的出生地。怎么样？
After Jim gets promoted, Dwight has a talking head where he just screams. And you can see Creed, like, jump out of his seat in the background? Was Creed actually startled by the noise? I mean, I have to say it looked like he was. They might have used the very first take. Yeah. And Creed maybe didn't realize how loud rain was going to be. Well, you know, in the shooting draft, that's the last scene. Oh. Yeah. But, and what made it to air, there was this lovely little ending scene between Meredith and Pam and Angela. I loved it. Pam is still trying to get her RSVP list finalized. And and she asked Meredith.
吉姆晋升后，德怀特有一个谈话头镜头，他只是尖叫。你可以看到克里德在背景中从座位上跳了起来？克里德真的被噪音吓到了吗？我是说，我不得不说看起来确实是。他们可能用了第一次拍摄的镜头。是的。而且克里德可能没意识到雷恩会叫得那么大声。好吧，你知道，在拍摄草稿中，那是最后一幕。哦。是的。但在播出的版本中，梅雷迪思、帕姆和安吉拉之间有这个可爱的结尾场景。我很喜欢。帕姆仍在努力敲定她的回复名单。她问梅雷迪思。
Is she coming? Meredith says, Niagara Falls in October, pheels, yeah. But then, you know, this scene plays out, we discussed it at the top of the show, where Meredith doesn't want to return
她会来吗？梅雷迪思说，十月的尼亚加拉大瀑布，感觉不错，是的。但你知道，这一幕上演了，我们在节目开头讨论过，梅雷迪思不想归还
her RSVP card. She'll just text Pam. If she wants ribs or not. And as Meredith leaves, Pam is clearly, like, frustrated, and Angela says rude about Meredith. Pam is so excited. She's like, yes.
她的回复卡。她会直接给帕姆发短信。她是否想要排骨。当梅雷迪思离开时，帕姆显然很沮丧，安吉拉说梅雷迪思很粗鲁。帕姆非常兴奋。她说，太好了。
And she's going to sit down and have a moment with Angela in the break room and maybe vent a little bit. But first she has to move Angela's purse onto the table. Pam, my bag was there. Yeah. There goes their moment. Over. It's done. They're never going to be friends.
她要在休息室和安吉拉坐下来聊一会儿，也许发泄一下。但首先她必须把安吉拉的钱包移到桌子上。帕姆，我的包在那儿。是的。他们的时刻就这样没了。结束了。他们永远不会成为朋友。
Well, there you have it, guys. That was the meeting. Next week, we have a very special episode of Office Ladies with a very special person. who we love. Who we love so much that Jenna is talking like this. We have a special part of fun. Well, he's fascinating. I can't wait for you guys to hear this interview.
好吧，伙计们，就是这样。这就是会议。下周，我们将有一期非常特别的《办公室女士》节目，有一位我们非常爱的人。我们非常爱他，以至于珍娜说话都变成这样了。我们有一段特别的乐趣。好吧，他很迷人。我迫不及待想让你们听到这次采访。
Have a fantastic week. Thanks for listening to Office Ladies. We're sending you a big, big hug through the microphone thingy. I like it. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration. with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and
祝你们度过愉快的一周。感谢收听《办公室女士》。我们通过麦克风给你们一个大大的拥抱。我喜欢这个。下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和
Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our second drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。我们的第二杯剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·菲佛。Odyssey的执行制片人是利亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。